(cheerful music)
- You have one week left
to get your Apari/Trash Taste merch.
(Joey yelling)
- [Connor] That's right.
Only one week left to
grab it. Grab it now!
- It has beautiful embroideries on it,
like the After Dark design
and the regular Trash Taste design,
as well as T-shirts and sweat pants.
Show it off Garnt.
- Look at this, look
at this, Look at this.
You know what, this is the first time
light mode is gonna look this good.
(Joey laughing)
- Yeah, it's embroidery we
wanted it to last this time.
The merch is a little bit
more pricey than before,
but it will last.
And it will be around for a long time.
And the quality is insane.
- We've promoted Apari many times
and every time their merch sells out.
So we know you love their quality.
- And of course for
every person who does buy
any of the Trash Taste items,
you'll get a special
personalized postcard from
the boys. Just for you.
- So you have one week
left to get your merch.
And I gotta be honest.
If you ever approach us
wearing this Trash Taste merch,
you'll get a firm crisp hug
and a handshake from me.
- A chef's kiss as
well. (Joey smacks lips)
- Maybe a kiss on the lips,
who knows, I don't know.
♪ It's the final countdown ♪
(Garnt and Joey mimicking final countdown)
- We can't get out on (Connor mumbling).
No copyright claim, no copyright claim.
- So if you'd like to grab your hands
on the Trash Taste merch
because after next week
it's gonna be gone forever.
Go down, links in the description below.
Grab some for yourself.
- Back to The episode.
(sound of water splashing)
- I need to hydrate man.
- Here's some water please?
- Oh dear my throat is awfully parched.
(Garnt sipping)
(Joey chuckles)
- Is it quenched now?
(gentle music)
Do you know where I learned
the words "Parched" and "Quenched?"
(Connor burps)
- [Garnt] Where?
- (chuckles) Nintendogs, really.
- [Connor] What? they use that language?
- (chuckles) Because in Nintendogs,
when it says that you need
to give your dog water,
it says "Parched."
And then when you give the dog water,
it says "Quenched." (Joey chuckles)
- I think I learned the word "Parched"
in from the film "Inside
Man" or "Inside Job."
I can't remember which one it is.
I think it's "Inside Man."
'Cause there's an interrogation.
There's an interrogation scene.
And the guy's like,
"Can you give me some water
please? My throat is parched."
And then the guy was just like,
"Bro, no one says their throat is parched.
(Joey laughs)
"Shut the fuck up!
"Shut the fuck up and
tell me what's going on?"
Hello and welcome to another
episode of Trash Taste.
(Joey laughs)
- Such a weird way
to remember a word.
- [Garnt] I don't know (chuckles).
- How vivid of a memory is this?
- So, where'd you guys
learn new words from?
Because Like sometimes...
- I just told you Nintendogs.
- Sometimes you just hear a word
and that like that sticks with you.
- Video games I learned
all my language form.
- Video games? Movies?
- Nowadays I pronounce
something incorrectly on,
on a fuckin video or livestream.
I got 10,000 comments and emails
telling me I pronounced it wrong.
And then, but it's a pretty
good way of learning.
- I thought English was your
first language bro. (chuckles)
- Yes hello this is Trash Taste.
It is I, the biggest Miku fan apparently.
(Joey giggling)
- I don't simp Garnt or I did.
(Garnt laughs)
you look like you're
about to on Idol concert
- Yeah so we're recording
two episodes today.
So we have to like change clothes.
I guess I just gave that away.
And there was nothing else in the office,
aside from Miku stuff.
(Joey laughs)
Today I am the biggest Miku fan.
And with me is of course
the second biggest Miku fan right now.
- (mumbles) Don't call me out.
This was Saddle merch bro,
TM saddle. (chuckles)
- I didn't even know that was Miku merch.
- Oh yeah it's Miku merch.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
If I turned around,
people would be able to see,
very clearly this is Miku.
- There's a big fat Miku on the back.
- We don't need to see that.
It's business in the front.
Front and the back
- And then there's just Joey.
the usual, whatever.
- Yay!
The actual Miku fan.
- Oh yeah and Merry Christmas everyone!
I guess...
- [Joey] Yay!
- I guess this is coming out on Christmas.
- It's also the last episode of the year.
Supposedly.
- [Connor] Yeah. Damn!
- Because the next episode is gonna be
coming out on 1st of January.
We didn't even plan that shit out.
- No, I guess that's just
how the stars aligned.
When did the last
episode come out of like,
did it come out on New Year's Eve
or did it come out on New Year's Day?
- I think It came out...
Yeah like New Year's Eve I think.
- 'Cause I remember I was
just getting drunk with Chris
and that was like the first
episode of the year right?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, so I think it must've been
after New Year's Day then.
- That doesn't feel like a year ago.
- [Garnt] (laughs) It doesn't.
- It feels like 10 years ago.
- My God, like where did this year go?
Because it feels like the past two years
have just like flown by.
- I mean 2020 just disappeared
in a flash obviously
because everyone was just
inside and depressed.
But, like this year I feel we were able
to go out a little bit
more, at least in Japan.
We're able to go out a little
bit more than last year.
But I think in our case we
just had so much shit going on
that it all just like, seems like a blur.
- I mean was, I thought
I was busy in 2020.
And then 2021 was like,
"Allow me to introduce myself."
And then, yeah...
- Every, like on the iPhone calendar.
Like when you have something
on the iPhone calendar,
like you have something on that day,
there's like a little dot to symbolize it.
So, it's very easy on iPhone to see
how busy your past couple of months were.
Because every month I
came up to the next month
and I was like, I'll be a
lot more free next month.
Like this month was super busy.
Next month though, no dots.
Enter that month, all dots.
(Garnt and Joey chuckling)
- Yeah, no time.
- It's like oh cool I have
three days off last month.
No wonder I'm fuckin tired.
- Yeah, it was really surreal seeing
just your calendar fill up.
Because I remember when
I first moved to Japan,
I thought, who needs a calendar?
We're YouTubers, we don't need calendars.
We make our own schedule.
You move to Japan and
slowly, you're just like,
maybe I need a calendar to just to like,
keep track of like one or two days.
And then more stuff keeps creeping in
and then you're just like, oh wait!
I need to put my personal
life for my calendar as well.
(Joey laughs)
Because like, now I don't know
when like my mates wanna hang out
if I have something going on that day.
It's so surreal just being this busy.
And I never expected to
be this busy in my life.
- I mean it's definitely
a good thing right?
Like it's a very...
it's definitely a very
privileged position I would say.
To be busy and doing
all sorts of cool stuff.
But at the same time,
it's only so much my body
can handle (Joey chuckles).
- You know that scene in like,
every like business movie,
where the CEO is like,
"Put it in my calendar."
(Joey laughing)
I thought that was just a cliche.
- "Deborah, pencil it in."
(Garnt laughing)
- "Oh, do I have time for this meeting?
"Put it in my calendar."
- It's only a matter of time
until we all have our own Deborah's
that have to pencil shit in for us.
- I think, I'd ironically
want an assistant.
(Group laughs)
- Yeah right?
- I know that sounds terrible.
I felt like what the fuck
I would never want one.
Then I'm like, oh actually,
then a lot of things could be helped.
But if I had someone to
help schedule things.
- Yeah, I know a couple
of like YouTuber friends
who live here that have
like personal assistants.
And I'm like oh my god that
seems like a fuckin lifesaver.
- Oh man the thought of having
to like speak to someone. (laughs)
And be like, "Hey my life's a mess.
"Can you help me?"
Like, it's not about that like, I feel...
I don't know how to explain it.
I'm embarrassed about having
to get my life in order.
You know what I mean? That's what it is.
So, it's like going to the doctor.
I don't want you to tell
me that I'm shit at health.
Like I know that. But
if I go to the doctor,
I'm gonna have 100%
confirmation that I'm unhealthy.
- I just don't wanna
be that guy who's like,
"Talk to my PA."
- Yeah.
- "Talk to my assistant."
(Joey gags)
- Let me say like, if you wanna like,
get permission for stuff.
Or get like, I don't know.
You're like okay I need to be able
to like arrange all the shit
can you help you do that I don't know.
But like, I mean some days like,
I don't know about three,
four days of the week.
I pretty much fill my schedule up,
from literally like eight
o'clock till like midnight.
- [Garnt] Yeah insightful.
- Yeah.
- Good stuff doing stuff.
But I like that, I liked doing it.
And livestreaming just
added a bunch of time
that it needs to be squished in there.
- I mean you've put more
work on yourself this year
'cause I feel like this year is the year
that you've really upped
your livestreaming schedule as like,
you basically have almost
like three channels now.
You got Trash Taste, you got...
- Your main channel.
And then you got...
- I do have three channels.
- Your livestream channel right?
- Yeah well, 'cause
now I'll do livestreams
in the morning or the evening.
So, if I'm not doing
something in the morning.
Let's say if I have
something at 12 o'clock.
Like we record Trash Taste...
Today we did to at it at 11.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
But if we did it at 12,
I would be like, all right sick.
I'll wake up at eight,
I'll livestream until 12, I'll come here.
And then I'll like work all day,
and then I'll go do
something in the evening.
And then I'll sleep.
This is why I can't watch shows actually.
This is what I've realized.
I literally have no time.
- Yeah same.
- I don't know what Joey's excuse is.
I'm like streaming until I sleep.
So I realized I have no time to watch TV.
- I literally have to pencil in
(Joey laughing)
the times I watch Anime now.
Because 'cause here's like the...
He's like the ultimatum of
every Anime YouTuber right?
'Cause a lot of the times,
it takes more work to make
a video about an Anime
than to watch an Anime.
So, I actually have to pencil in okay,
this is the time I'm going to put in
into making a video about Anime.
And here's the time that I have
to pencil in to watch Anime.
And like the time I pencil in
to watch Anime is like this.
The time I pencil in to
make videos is like that.
- [Joey and Connor] Yeah.
- This is like the equivalent like doctors
having to like study new practices
to stay on top of their game.
And so I have to watch Anime, it's R&D
- I just love to think
that like, if I was like,
if someone was like a mate
of Garnt's so he was like,
"Hey Garnt, do you wanna like
hang out on X day at X time."
And Garnt's just being like,
"Sorry man that's Anime time."
(Group laughs)
- literally there've been
times where Sydney's like,
"Oh Garnt can we hang out on this night?"
And I'm like, "Sorry Sydney,
it's my Anime watching hour.
"And it's part of my job.
I need to keep up with like
"What's airing right now."
- My friends laugh at me
'cause I have to like ask them.
I have to like, I send them
emails, like invitations,
to like times, to like hang out.
- I'm like, "Let's hang
out, I'll send you an email.
"To like put it in your calendar."
'Cause I'll forget.
- You send them like a
Google calendar notification.
- I think about like the last 10 times
I agreed to hang out with
someone at least on like a call,
not like in-person,
I've never liked not turned up in person.
But my on-call to hang out with people,
I feel like I don't get to see often
or people who live in other countries.
- I think like the last five out of 10
that I didn't put in my calendar,
I think I like turned up
late or just forgot about.
- [Garnt] Yeah, if I don't put in...
- I feel terrible about that,
I'm a bad friend but yeah.
- If I don't put it in my calendar,
because sometimes you get like free time
or you think you get free time.
You're like,
do I actually have free time?
- You think you have free time
- So you say, you whip out
the calendar and you're like,
"Oh I do have free time."
Then an hour passes and you
get message and you're like,
"Oh, weren't you meant to be...
"We're meant to be having a call.
"We're meant to be hanging
out." And you're like,
"Oh fuck! It's a lie! It's a lie!"
- For me It's like, for
me the problem is like,
going back to like the
apple calendar thing,
I'm like all right, finally.
I wake up and I'm like finally.
A day where the dot is non-existent.
(Garnt laughs)
I have a day off.
I can do whatever the fuck I want.
But then I go to my computer.
I look at my other schedule
that's sitting at my desk and I'm like,
oh, I have to edit three
videos and do two sponsors.
All right, so it's not a day off.
It's a day to be inside.
But I'm not necessarily
doing anything outside.
So, it's not a day off.
And yeah, that's been my
life for the past two years.
- Do you guys have to-do lists?
- I've been starting to
like do to-do lists now
because I have to forget
what I have to do.
- To-do list, the day I
discovered to-do lists,
like to do it late.
(Garnt giggling)
- Like a Caveman turning over a rock.
- Yeah game-changer.
- "There was a list of
things I had to do it.
"It changed my mind."
- I don't even think cavemen were
that impressed when they
discovered fire like,
'cause like one of my friends...
- How do you get
(Joey laughing)
these easy tips?
- Honestly dude like,
especially when it comes to like Al stuff,
because we have so many
things that we have to do,
and so many things that
we want to do right.
So, my dad actually taught me like
how to make the perfect to-do list,
which is you wake up in the morning
and you think to yourself all right,
you jot down everything
that you can think of
that you can do, and that you have to do.
You jot it down and then from that list,
everything that is super
important goes to the top.
Else that can wait a couple
of days goes to the bottom.
And then you go on with your day,
you tick off everything that you do.
And at the end of the day,
if you're left with a couple
of things, that's all right.
That becomes the top of your
to-do list the next day.
- And just, I've been doing
that for the past year
and I've become infinitely productive.
Like I guarantee you that's what
Mudan does as well probably.
With the amount of shit he has to do like.
- I'm like, "How do I find
more hours in the day Mudan?
"You seem to like pull from
this infinite pool of hours
"That I don't know where you find."
- I don't want it, mere
mortals aren't meant to
have that level of productivity...
- I (chuckles) threw away
my humanity long ago.
- We don't wanna wield
that level of productivity.
- I just wanna know what
did Mudan sacrifice?
You know what? (chuckles)
- I think he like cooked...
- What did it cost? Everything!
- I think he hooked his
like brain in car (mumbles)
Like brain and heart with car battery.
(Garnt laughs)
It's just like
constantly just going.
- I can't wait for him to
come on and explain himself.
- "So just don't sleep."
- He's awful at like
explaining how he's productive.
Like he doesn't make it
sound realistic at all.
- Yeah, he's just like,
"I just wake up in the
morning and just do it."
He's the epitome of just get good.
- Yeah, like with Mudan,
I only see like the input and output.
Like input, editing work. Output, a video.
I don't see like what happens.
It's basically just
like a black box right.
It's like the YouTube
algorithm, because like,
you kinda know how it works,
but no one really knows
the inner workings of
the YouTube algorithm.
That's just like Mudan
and editing for me man.
- Have you ever seen Mudan edit?
(Garnt and joey laughing)
- The only time I've seen
him edit, is on stream.
And that's where he's also
doing something else while he's editing.
- He's probably like holding
back on streams as well
as people don't get freaked out.
- Certainly using 2% Of the brain.
(Group laughs)
- Sorry. (chuckles)
- Honestly, that's how impressive
it is because it's like,
I think, people already
know who watched the show
are aware of just how much
he edits for Trash Taste.
And also for me and Connor.
But I think people forget that,
other people also ask him to edit.
- He's editing for Sydney now as well.
- Yeah, right.
- So, I'm just glad.
- And not to mention he
edits his own streams
and he streams.
- And he also streams as well!
- And he also streams
like pretty regularly.
So I'm Like, what? How?
- Man's a beast! Man's a beast!
- I would like to know what...
Mudan what is your secret?
- When he comes.
- When you come on,
when he come on,
- He can tell us.
- Please, please...
- The long awaited episode.
- We're also waiting for
the country to open back up
which hopefully will finally
happen next year as well.
- It's like in part what I'm saying ish.
- That's the biggest thing I'm hoping for.
- I mean it's gonna happen next year.
It's just when, it's like,
is it gonna happen early or
late, that's the big question.
- I think everyone is saying like,
as early as maybe Feb
or March right I think.
- March would be nice.
- Visitors can come in,
because right now I think,
if you're a non-visitor,
so if you're like a student,
or you're on work visa or stuff like that,
you can technically come in now.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Not that I've seen any actual examples
of people coming in.
- I assume they need to get...
I haven't looked into the process,
but I assume they need to
reapply for some kind of
application because not tourists,
but at least if you have a working visa,
or you've been waiting,
for like a job or to study here
then you can come here which is good.
Which is like,
it shouldn't have taken two
years to get to this point.
- I feel bad for the students man.
- Yeah I know right?
- Just being like finally I get to live
my dream of coming to Japan.
- No it makes me feel so bad
because like when we applied,
we had to wait like what, three months?
And that was just like
the worst three months by.
'Cause it's not the fact
that it's three months.
It's the fact that it's three
months where you don't know
what's gonna happen to your life.
And you're just like your
life's kind of in limbo
until you get that confirmation
to be like, "Oh, okay,
finally, I can start packing.
"I can start preparing to go." And then...
But while you're waiting,
you're just like,
"Uh should I start? Should I go?
"What's kind of going on with
me in my life right now."
- I was wondering with
the students things,
I was thinking like okay,
we had no way of knowing that
it was gonna take two
years for Japan to open.
And like, I don't know what,
I actually haven't really
spoken to any students about it.
But like, what was like,
if you got to like,
you're like day one right.
You find out Japan is closing.
Like, do you just like,
wait and see, or do you just
decide to do something else?
And then like hope,
and hope that you can just then go back?
I don't know?
- I think for most students,
I don't think anyone was anticipating them
to fuckin stay in limbo
for two years right?
So, I'm sure the majority
of students were like,
"Oh, I still got time, I can wait."
- Oh fuck imagine losing
two years of like,
I guess, progress you could
have made in your 20s.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But then again, it's
not really that important
because I guess a lot of people
in life didn't start doing
their main thing until they were like 40s.
So I guess it really
doesn't fuckin matter.
- Oh yeah, yeah, true, true.
- I mean but, I think what sucks
is that you just have two years where
you can't really commit to something.
That's what really sucks for me,
where I always want to have a goal
that I'm working towards
and know that I'm actively
working towards that goal.
'Cause one of my biggest
pet peeves is like,
if I'm feeling like I'm not
working towards something,
then I just feel lost.
And I just feel like a fuckin lost soul.
And I need something
concrete to work towards.
That's why like I really empathize
with anyone waiting for a visa.
And thank God you guys
can finally come here.
- Hopefully we get here soon,
get to eat some tsukemen.
(Joey laughs)
- That's the number one thing.
Fuck the sushi.
- Don't get tsukemen.
- Fuck the ramen.
go to your local tsukemen joint
and discover true happiness.
- Then we've the Michelin Star ramen.
- Oh yeah we do.
- And it was very...
We didn't know it was Michelin Star right?
- It was a place Maylin recommended to us.
- Was it ramen? Because
I thought it was soba.
- [Connor] No, it's ramen.
- It's like Chuka-soba,
which is like Chinese soba,
which is like, technically
ramen, some people call it ramen.
- The noodles are more ramen noodle.
- It was very light for a ramen.
- It was very light yeah.
- 'Cause like when you said
like ramen, I was just like,
"Oh, it's going to be a heavy ramen,"
'cause ramen is the kind of meal
that like takes you out.
It knocks you out for like an hour
because of how heavy it is.
- It's like the thin
noodle ramen I guess...
- It was very nice, it was good,
it was light.
- It was good but...
When I was thinking about it, I'm like,
okay what do I...
I think I have the wrong
expectations of Michelin Star.
Like I expect some kind of
stupid luxurious-like gourmet thing,
but I guess it's more about value,
the food you get.
- It was like 1000 Yen.
At least the one I got was like 10 bucks.
- Yeah, I mean like $8 right?
- Yeah, it's amazing,
I have a picture of it, I put up on...
- It was very good but the
whole time I was thinking,
I was like, "I think
tsukemen is more tasty there"
- I think so as too.
- I think so as well.
- The bulk standard tsukemen
which was better than
the Michelin Star ramen.
- I agree. Honestly, I didn't
enjoy the ramen that much.
And I got okay, 'cause
here's the thing right?
I feel like Michelin Star, if
you've been to enough of them,
especially in Japan, 'cause it's like,
in Japan there's so many
Michelin Star restaurants,
but I've realized that,
with Michelin Star, you come in with like
the wrong expectations right?
And this is gonna make me sound,
this is gonna make me sound
so fuckin privileged and all,
"Michelin Stars aren't
all that great but..."
- [Connor] Where's the
Michelin Star Garnt? Tell them.
- It's a Michelin Star, but like,
here's the thing right.
- The Tire Man? No!
(Group laughs)
- Like here's the thing.
When you go into a
Michelin Star restaurant,
your expectations are like
up here, you're like...
- Scott knows all well
because he often frequents
the Michelin Star
- [Garnt] Of course, of course.
No but like, you come in
with these expectations
that you're gonna get like a meal
that's a cut above the rest right?
And so you start judging things harsher
than if you just go to
this random restaurant
and just like find out
that there's like amazing food.
'Cause in Japan, I feel like there is
just as many restaurants that have food
that are like Michelin Star quality,
that just haven't been discovered yet?
And, and to me like,
Michelin Star isn't
always the indicator of,
this is the best meal
that you can get in Japan.
But it only means is that.
It's become famous enough
that people have started to notice it.
But there are so many hidden gems.
And like, for example, with
the Michelin Star ramen,
that is not like the best,
even the best ramen that I've had,
the best tsukemen that I've had.
- I've had like sketchy ass places
that were a little bit
better. (Connor laughs)
- I honestly think the insect ramen
I had from my video was actually better.
- No!
- And that had 150 crickets in it.
- I'm not shitting on this one.
We haven't named the ramen place.
'cause I also don't
wanna like fuckin make...
- I'm saying that because the insect ramen
was actually fuckin amazing.
- No. And also like,
because it's Michelin Star,
it actually made it a worse
experience for me right?
Because you wait in line...
- Because your expectations
are too high right?
- One, yeah expectations is high.
And two, it's really,
really fuckin busy right?
So, in this ramen shop,
it's a tiny ass ramen shop.
It's like, when we say
Michelin Star, it's a really...
It's a normal ramen shop.
- Ramen stores in general are like not...
I would say they're
good dining experiences.
If you wanna come here and
chill out with your friends,
don't go to a ramen place.
- It's a come in,
eat, and go.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I mean that place only seats like what?
10, 12 people maybe?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah exactly.
- It's busy, it's like narrow.
You're like, if you're
even remotely large,
then larger than normal,
you're gonna have a tough
time squeezing past everyone.
It's like not fine.
- [Garnt] Unlike,
We went at about 2:00 pm.
So not even like, not
even close to peak time
and we still had to wait
like a good 20 minutes.
Like a good 20 minutes.
And this is when the country
is closed to tourists,
so when tourists come back in...
I was talking to some people
who've waited for this ramen
for like an hour, an hour
and a half, two hours right?
And you get shepherd in,
and then you're expected
to just eat the ramen and leave right?
There's no downtime.
You get given a bowl,
you eat it and then leave.
You can't like, to me, part
of like the food experience,
is just like, not feeling
pressured to eat the food,
but just...
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But just like, feeling like,
I can take my time to enjoy this food.
- I couldn't even like bask.
Like as good as the ramen was,
I couldn't bask in it because
there was the pressure of all.
I could take my time with this,
but I'd also be pissing
off the 20 other people
still waiting in line right?
- [Garnt] Exactly right, exactly.
- Standing outside.
- This is why I've realized
that ramen is best at like midnight.
- You can just like...
- They take their time with it.
- They always serve beers.
Everyone's having like
a good time in there,
like it's a way more fun atmosphere.
Like some of the stores
that are open 24 hours
normally have a few more seats as well.
- It is the ultimate
midnight snack for sure.
- Honestly it's awful for your stomach.
(Joey chuckles)
There's a good chance you
might like bring it back up.
But some of the best
ramen experiences I've had
are like midnight.
We're in like a sketchy area
of some place in Japan.
Everyone's drinking beers in the store,
it's cool atmosphere, everyone's talking.
It's so much more fun
than ramen during the day
where everyone's just
there to eat and get out.
- Yeah, the best ramen experience I had
was when I was absolutely shit faced,
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
at like 2:00 am.
And then my friend Makoto was like,
(Joey speaking Japanese)
at like 2:00 am and I was like, uh okay.
So, we ran around the corner
to this like awful sketchy place.
Like the ramen wasn't even
that good bu just like...
- It's just fun.
When the moment I went
down, I was like damn!
Good to feel alive.
But then the moment you
walk out it's like...
- Oh it's awful.
- 'Cause you've ruined your stomach
with all the alcohol.
- Be right back in the diner.
- 'Cause to me like the
restaurant experience
goes beyond just the
taste of the food right?
There's like a reason
why your mom's cooking
always tastes fuckin good right?
It's 'cause like...
'Cause that cooking mean
something to you (stutters).
- "Where's the heart man?
Where's the heart in the ramen?"
(Connor laughs)
- Honestly, honestly!
you can taste in some Japanese restaurants
where they put the heart to the cooking.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah.
- Like it's so obvious with
some like very small shops.
- I mean I just think that I just,
I realized that I don't like ramen
as much as I want to like ramen.
Like I Uber Eats tsukemen on sometimes.
And that shit is fuckin good.
Because also ramen travels terribly.
That's why I never, ever order ramen.
I mean unless you have like one of those
really old style ones,
where they like, bring you actual bowl
with everything in it.
- That's the only one I get.
- Problem is nowadays with
ramen, with Uber Eats.
They separate the noodles and the broth.
So they just give you a broth
in like a plastic thing.
- Really?
- A lot of the time yeah.
They don't actually put the noodles in.
You have to put the noodles in yourself.
Yeah it's not good.
And the noodles are supposed to be
like piping hot in the broth.
So, it doesn't really work.
But tsukemen, it travels
pretty okay, 'cause you...
- It's because the broth is
so thick, it's like magma.
It stays hot forever.
- The Broth is so thick
It stays really hot,
and then the noodles are
supposed to be separate anyway.
And then you just dunk the noodles in
and it's almost as good as you get it.
- Definitely better than shop at but yeah.
- But like if you need that itch.
- So, I've been saying man.
I've been advocating for.
- Because like ramen is
that one Japanese dish
where before I moved to Japan,
I was thinking oh,
I'm gonna eat ramen every
fuckin week, every day.
- I realize I've had ramen
three times in the past week. (chuckles)
But I didn't have ramen for
like months before that.
- Yeah, I was saying like the last time
I had ramen before we went to this
Michelin Star ramen place,
was like I think...
- A year before.
That's just because I have like
zero craving for ramen.
'Cause why would I have ramen
when I can have tsukemen right?
Like but the one dish that
I haven't got bored off though is sushi.
Like I eat sushi at least once a week.
- Really?
- At least once a week.
(Garnt laughs)
- You eat it more than me,
And I love sushi.
I'd probably go maybe like
two or three times a month.
- I wish there was like a really
quick and easy one near my house.
I would probably go.
I don't wanna order it.
- Yeah no, it doesn't order well.
But like, I feel like there's a few
conveyor belts sushis near my place,
and it's just perfect for lunch man.
It's quick, it's easy.
- They're like 100 Yen,
'cause even like the 100 Yen sushi,
which is like 80 cents
for like one piece of
like salmon or something.
It's so good.
- Yeah, honestly like my experience
with sushi in Japan is that, I've also...
Maylin has taken me
to some Michelin Star sushi places as well
- But of course she has.
- Maylin only eats if there's
(Garnt laughs)
Michelin man inside.
She's like, "I don't see
the Michelin man anywhere,
"I'm not going in."
- Basically part of the big reason
why we've gone to more
Michelin Star places
is because Maylin suggested
these places to us.
- Maylin swears by it.
- Yeah, which is how we
found the ramen place.
which is Maylin
recommended the ramen place
and it happens to be Michelin Star.
But I have tried like, a few like,
a lot of different sushi places
of like different price points.
And my honest opinion is that like sushi,
you reach about like,
you reached about like
$30 a meal for a sushi,
which is about, mid range
sushi in Japan right?
It's not cheap, it's not expensive.
And that's about as good as it gets to me,
because you can get sushi
from like $30, like $100, like $200.
- Gourmet, super famous
chefs out there like,
(Connor whispers)
"How dare you cunt?
"How dare you?"
- Unlike, my honest opinion is that
I've had the expensive sushi,
and I'm just like, it's better,
but it's not that much better
than like the $30 sushi
that I can get.
- That's how it's always is there.
Like I find the meals there
are a little more pricey
than the normal ones,
are generally like the nice ones.
And then when you get to the stupid
extravagant levels of prices,
it's like not that worth it.
- It's like a 10-fold increase
for like a five to 10% better meal.
- I think I would argue that like
if you're ever gonna go to like,
especially like the high,
high-end sushi places,
which is all around Tokyo,
then like get something
that you could only get
in that high-end restaurant.
So like, 'cause I remember
I took my friend Luke
to like the really high-end sushi place
'cause he's never been to
like a high-end sushi place.
So, I took him to the one in Harajuku.
It was like 400 bucks
between the two of us.
So it's like really high-end.
- Just some rice
and a bit of fish, oh lord!"
- But that place has like, I think,
I don't know if you guys have been to it.
But like it's the one where you can have
like the nine different
types of sea urchin
- That's nine different
types of sea urchin.
- So they do this like special thing.
- I don't even want one type, fuck!
- So there's a special thing
where they do like nine
different types of sea urchin.
- Why are talking about sushi
and we haven't had lunch yet.
(Joey chuckles)
- And you get like...
- My stomach's just like
(Garnt makes rumbling sounds)
- And you can like taste test.
Like the different types
of sea urchin from like
different parts of Japan and
around the world and stuff.
And like that is like cool because...
- [Garnt] I'm literally salivating.
- I'll give you $0.
(Group laughs)
- Like that is cool because
I've only ever seen that in that store.
Like yeah it's expensive,
but that is an experience
that you can only get in that store,
you can't go to like a fuckin
sushi chain for a sea urchin.
But like if you can just kind of
go to a high-end sushi place
and just order fuckin salmon on the ice,
so then like, there's no point,
there's no difference, like you're not...
The average person is not
that much of a sushi snob
where they gonna be like,
"Oh this isn't the high-grade salmon
"that they're using uh boo!"
- It's just like, even if
it's high-grade salmon,
it's like 5% increase on how
better the taste is right?
And sushi is basically just,
it's rice, it's the fish,
it's the wasabi, and it's just like the...
Soy sauce they put on top,
and like it's basically,
you just have to like,
make sure the ratios is all right.
And then there's only like
so much the fish can be fresh right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- At which point do we just like say,
"Hey, you just can't make
this taste any better
"with the ingredients you're
given," right, because...
- Unless you have like
10 times the number of taste
buds than the average human,
like it's not gonna change yeah.
- [Garnt] Exactly.
Like my tongue doesn't...
Like I'm not part of like
Shokugeki or something.
I can't taste the exact percentage
of salinity in the fuckin bitch.
- Although I must say when I did try
the nine different types
of like sea urchins,
I was ready to take my shirt off
from how good it was.
Just like, Ah! (Joey laughs)
- I'm just an unagi fan man.
It's my favorite food in Japan,
unagi. It's the best man.
- Yeah but see like even like unagi right?
Like after a certain
price range it's like...
You can't taste the difference.
- But like that's why like,
if you could just go to an unagi place,
it's kind of expensive unagi in general,
but I mean even like the
lower-lower price point ones,
I'm always like satisfied,
I'm always very happy.
- Yeah exactly.
- And I think it's somewhat
good for you, so that's good.
- Is it?
- It's not terrible.
- It's not terrible for you.
- It's got a lot of like,
a lot of good omegas, those fishy oils.
- But they are also going extinct as well.
That's the reason why
their prices are getting
higher and higher.
- Well, is it like Japan
it's like 80% of the
world eels or something.
- Something like that yeah.
- But then there's tons of
eels from other countries.
It's like most of Japan's eels
that is like nearly eaten to extinction.
- They're like almost all gone.
That's why they're just getting
more and more expensive.
- Yeah.
- I saw like a whole Business
Insider video on that.
- Yeah, 'cause Japan has a thing about,
"We don't wanna import foreign things.
"It's lower quality."
- Well they're starting
like eel farms now.
- Yeah, they import the eels
as babies from other countries
then grow them in Japan like,
they're Like, "The Japanese eels."
- It's like, "It's just
like Japanese eels."
- Half of eels
- Which is why...
(Group laughs)
- Which is why I realized,
when you go to a restaurant
and they serve you,
this like really expensive dish
or really expensive meats right?
That doesn't necessarily
mean it tastes any better,
because a lot of it's like, a
lot of more expensive meats,
weren't that expensive in history right?
So, the taste hasn't changed.
Like for example lobsters.
They used to be like...
- Peasant food.
- Yeah they used to be
like peasant food or...
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- Caviar? Peasant food, peasant food.
- You can't say peasant food without
someone laughing in the office.
- Tide pods used to be
peasant food, now gourmet.
- [Crew] Salmon used to
be peasant food as well.
- Yeah, and how the hell would I know.
- Is salmon like peasant food?
(Group laughs)
- At sushi restaurants it is.
- Most of the time right.
These fuckin restaurants,
the ones that are like the super high-end,
you feel so fuckin out of place
'cause you're not like
an oligarch from Russia.
I don't feel like I belong there.
I wanna go to the place
that has a cool vibe.
Yeah the food's a little more pricey
than going into like
Yoshinoya or something.
It's like a little bit more.
You get a vibe, you have a chill time,
there's no expectations.
You don't have to worry about
how you've been dressed.
That's the vibe I like,
- Yeah.
- It's a nice time.
I just wanna have my $12 burger.
That's like, "It's
better than McDonald's,"
but it's got a little gourmet,
but it's not gourmet,
but they put avocado on it or something.
I don't know, I don't know.
Just that middle price point
is my comfort zone and I'm like,
" This is nice."
- I just wanna feel like
the cooks and the chef
care about their food.
- I think that's a big thing for me.
- Yeah, when I order a
drink and they ask me
if it tastes okay before
they serve it to me,
that's when I feel like
I'm out of my depth.
I'm like, "I've never done this
before, I ordered the thing,
"you give me the thing."
- "Is that Michelin Star
water fitted for your needs?"
- If I order a wine,
just give me the wine.
Even if I told you it doesn't taste good,
you should just be, you
should just laugh at me
and be like, "Well, that's
you did bad so laugh."
- It's the small things. If
I get served food and like,
they come to an ask like, "Oh, how was it?
"Was it good?" I'm just
like, "You know what?
"You care enough to like
care about my opinion."
- I meant as in like,
they're gonna take it back if I say no.
- Not like, "Am I enjoying it?"
- But that's the kind of restaurants that,
when they bring out the dish or whatever,
and you'll look at it and
you're like, "What is this?"
And then a light novel title
of explanation starts right?
And it's like, "Can I just eat it?"
(Group laughs)
It's like two bites.
I would be done by the time
you finished explaining this
(Garnt laughs)
and I wouldn't care otherwise.
Those are the ones where
I'm like, if I said,
if they came up to me and they
were like, "Was it any good?"
And if I hypothetically said no,
then they would be like,
"What can we do to help you sir?"
- 'Cause like what the
experience I remember
was during the cycling special
where we went to that
restaurant with that grandma
who was basically just like eyeballing us
as we were eating the food.
- She pretty much
pulled up a chair and sat with us.
(Group laughs)
- It was like aunt feeding,
you know what I'm saying?
- [Garnt] Yeah (laughs), yeah, exactly.
- I was so fed.
- I loved that place though.
- It's just 'cause like when someone,
'cause I get it,
'cause like when you
cook a meal for someone
and they enjoy the food,
and they think it tastes good.
Like there's such, like
such a rush to that right.
And I feel like I've seen enough chefs
who, obviously it is a job.
I understand, some people
just do it for a job,
but there's just a magic
to a chef or a cook
who cooks the food,
and just get such an enjoyment
from seeing people enjoy their food right?
I don't know, it doesn't just...
This isn't just chefs but you know,
if I just see someone enjoying their job,
that just makes my day better.
Even if you just go to a fuckin McDonald's
and you see like that one
person with a genuine smile
and you're just like,
"You know what, good for you man.
"You're having a good time
working in McDonald's,
"I'm fuckin happy."
- I don't know man, if it
wasn't McDonald's, I'd be like,
"Oh, someone's getting blackmailed."
- 'Cause you ordered a Mac smile Garnt.
(Garnt laughs)
- Can I get
a smile for that one?
- Which for some reason
on Uber Eats in Japan
at the bottom of the page
where you just order all the stuff,
there was a Mac smile option for zero Yen.
And I don't understand
how you would purchase sad Mac smile?
Because I'm not there to see the smile.
- Is that natural?
- Genuinely go to Uber Eats.
- Because in Japan if you...
- My day's ruined, it is a lie.
- In Japan if you go into
a McDonald's restaurant
and you say, "Can I get a smile, please?"
Then they'll give it to you. They have to.
- And I was fine with that right?
I don't agree with that.
I don't think someone
should have to smile upon being requested.
But, why the fuck on Uber
Eats is it listed when...
- Is the Uber delivery
guy gonna smile for you?
- I don't know. 'Cause
I don't even see him
'cause they have, they
fuckin drop it off my door.
- It's fuckin like take like an InstaMax.
(Group laughs)
And just slide it under the door.
- The fuckin Uber driver
just takes a picture
of the McDonald's employee just smiling.
I don't understand why Uber
added this to the menu?
I'm like for what?
I don't understand how this is gonna work.
I added it one time and nothing happened.
- Because it's legally part
of the McDonald's menu.
- Because obviously
nothing is gonna happen
when I ordered the Mac
Smile via Uber Eats.
Because what would happen?
I was just curious.
- Is this a Japan exclusive thing?
- Japan exclusive.
- Of course it is.
- It would never work in the UK.
Employees would quit on the spot.
They'd be like, "I'd
rather die than smile."
- [Crew Member] I mean it's
the same with McDonald's here.
It's like, yeah you wanna
smile, "Please order it."
- There you go.
- Yeah.
(Garnt laughs)
- And it's like an actual
menu item in Japan.
- These poor workers are being
forced to smile upon request.
- At least give them
like a tip or something.
- You can't tip.
- You can't tip though.
- You can't tip here.
So what's the reason for smiling?
"Oh, it's because the
customer ordered me to smile."
"Smile, enjoy your job."
(Group laughs)
- I want someone to encourage me
as I ordered these 30 nuggets,
that will inevitably destroy my body.
- What I enjoy seeing someone smile
without me having to order them to smile.
(Joey laughs)
You know?
- But in Japan you're like,
you don't know if they're doing it,
'cause they have to do it.
- Yeah, Japan is the
master of business smiles
at the end of the day.
- Yeah.
- I feel like I've been
to enough places...
in Japan
- Some places I know
- Where I'm just like,
okay, this is like the corporate
smile I'm watching now.
- Yeah, because there's no way.
If you turn up like half
drunk to a McDonald's
that they are happy to see you there,
that stumbly ordering of a cheeseburger.
You know what I mean?
Like there's no way anyone
is happy about that.
(Joey mimics a drunk person)
- "Excuse me, Can I get
"a smile with that please?"
(Connor mimics a drunk person)
- Ah! Big Mac,
(Connor speaking Japanese)
- I see maids in Akihabara and guys,
I don't think they're really happy
(Joey laughs)
to talk to the customers.
I don't know man.
Maybe they're just not excited
to talk to the people that they seem like
they want to talk to.
- When you watch someone smile,
but their eyes aren't smiling?
That's all the maids in Akihabara.
(Garnt laughs)
They sound so cheaper.
And they have a big smile on their face
as they're waving to you like this.
But deep in their eyes
is just, "I wanna die."
- Oh, the industry's also dying.
So, you can't be too happy about that.
I mean there's like significant amount
less of maid stores or cafes but then.
- But now they all have masks on.
So they're probably not even
smiling under the mask either.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- A God sign.
- How can you tell if they're smiling now?
- They've perfected the,
"I sound happy without smiling voice."
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
(Connor sings in Japanese)
Just like that behind the uniform.
(Joey sings in Japanese)
(crew sings in japanese)
- Good they shouldn't have to smile.
I'm all for people not needing to smile.
- That's all right, I wasn't gonna go
into those maid cafes anyways.
(Connor laughs)
So don't worry about it.
- Really Joey, really?
- I've been to one, it fuckin sucked.
- Wow.
- I've been to one as well.
- We've established many
times on this podcast,
that they are the worst thing on earth.
- They are the worst.
Have you been on one?
- No, I don't need to go to one to know
(Joey laughs)
I don't want to get to one.
I'm violently uncomfortable by it.
- It's an experience, you
should try it at least once.
- [Garnt] It's so uncomfortable.
- It's like the most
un-British thing on earth
and I can't do it.
And I've seen like,
so like Offline TV went to one
and I'm like, I can just only imagine
how awkward this was when they went there,
like this is terrible.
- I would go back solely for the reason
to take Chris with me.
- That would be an amazing video,
"Taking Chris to a maid cafe."
- There's a lot of things I would do
just to make Chris suffer.
(Joey laughs)
And to make myself
suffer as well.
- Can I take you and Chris to a maid cafe?
(Garnt laughs)
- Sure, you should.
- We'll see how you guys react to that.
- Sure, why not.
- "Trash Taste maid
cafe special," That's...
- But promise Chris's
reaction's often off camera
are almost funnier than his
on camera reactions.
- Yeah they are.
- 'Cause, he'll just be like,
"Shit! That was shit! Connor
why do you made me do that?"
- Seem Chris and you're like
the love-love beam or whatever.
I can't remember
what they say...
- Oh my God!
- Are they Mohicun cun?
Oh the Mohicun cun.
- Oh my God!
- That's it.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- I wanna see Chris do that dude.
- Chris has gone to the point where
he's just the most entertaining,
miserable British man.
Like he's so funny to watch be miserable.
ause he's perfected the art of like,
you don't feel bad for making him angry
(Connor laughs).
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
Like some people when they
get upset or uncomfortable,
you're like you feel sorry for them.
But Chris has perfected the way of like,
you just don't feel bad for
laughing at Chris when he's...
- He's the only man that can somehow laugh
while having a frown
on his face.
- Yeah exactly.
- But what's so good about being British.
The people don't feel
bad for laughing at you
when you're uncomfortable.
(Connor laughs)
'Cause people they're
just like, they're like,
"Oh! he's having a horrible time.
(Joey laughs)
"It's funny, it's great."
- Like to me with maid cafes,
like to me it's the perfect
determiner to see if
someone's like a lost soul when
it comes to differentiating
between like Anime and real life.
'Cause if you go to like,
if he goes to like a maid cafe
and you don't feel uncomfortable,
then to me that makes me feel like...
- Ripperoni.
- Ripperoni, he's a lost soul right now.
Because maids are meant to act
like Anime characters right?
And there's nothing
more uncomfortable to me
than seeing like a real
life Anime character,
like right in front of my eyes.
- Well because in real life
it's like extremely uncomfortable
to see somebody talk that way.
It's like, "Please just act normal..."
- Cause people do not that way.
- "Please just act normal,"
"What did you say, I'm begging you.
"Please I don't know,
slap me or something.
"I don't know anything but this."
- Just talk to me like a human being,
please, please.
- [Joey] Yeah exactly.
This episode is sponsored by Shadowverse.
Shadowverse is an awesome Anime card game
featuring great art with
a fun loving community
of over one million daily battles.
- Gentlemen, did you also know that
it's free to play on mobile and PC?
Yeah, I know.
- Damn!
- And if you sign up now,
they gonna give you a super generous deal
that you get 53 card packs just
for completing the tutorial.
- And don't forget it has
an amazing Anime art style
that is fully voiced
in both English and Japanese.
- Damn!
- It is highly strategic to play
with eight distinct leader classes
and a multitude of cards designed by
some of the world's
best card game players.
- And I heard there's a new
expansion and collaboration
that will be coming out
at the end of December, 2021.
- Very nice.
- All right now the script part's over,
(Group laughs)
this game slaps, okay?
I'm gonna be real, look,
if you know me,
you know I actually
genuinely love Shadowverse.
It's an amazing card game.
I've reached Grandmaster in it twice now.
And I can reach it a third time
if I really wanted to.
- Just casual flex.
- Just a casual flex.
I can reach it anytime I want.
It's a great game, go play it.
- All right, well that's
Garnt's honest opinion.
And that genuinely is his honest opinion.
(Joey laughs)
Look, so if you also
wanna go play it,
make sure to use that link
in the description down below
to download Shadowverse today.
- Back to the show.
- Considering this is
(soft upbeat music)
our year episode.
What have you guys been
up to this year then?
What's been the biggest growth?
The biggest disappointments?
The biggest achievements?
Have you achieved anything this year?
- I'm not dead.
(Joey chuckles)
Still alive I guess.
- Still alive I guess.
- Yeah.
What have you achieved Connor?
- Not much really.
(Joey and Garnt chuckles)
- We all say that, but
I think to our audience,
it's like, "I can name
off about 50 things."
- We have moved studios.
We've got a merch with...
- This is probably the
biggest achievement.
- This is probably the biggest thing.
- It's difficult 'cause you don't...
Often you don't wanna spend too much time
patting yourself on the back,
because if you do,
you often get lost in that.
- You become, be considered yeah.
- You wanna keep pushing forward
and never be complacent
with what you've done.
I mean, I guess I'm happy I moved house.
It didn't really feel like
something that I've achieved,
but I felt like it was a big dub.
Get moving to a better place.
- You know that's all right man,
sometimes, you have to stroke
your own dick sometimes
to feel good.
- I know I know.
- That's the only way...
- Definitely a minus is
the gym has been less apparent in my life.
I need to get back soon.
- It has been
non existent in my life
- I'm just happy,
Connor can I say where we used to live?
We can say the area
- We can say Saitama.
- So, I'm glad we've moved out of Saitama.
(Garnt chuckles)
- Yeah we did.
- So, all that time when we said
that we lived in Tokyo,
that was a fuckin lie.
Well, we lived in Saitama at the time.
- Not exactly, it's the greater
Tokyo Metropolitan area.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- It wasn't like...
- Is zone six really London?
- Saitama is massive.
Saitama is a fuckin massive location.
- It's like three times the size of Tokyo.
- We lived in like the area that was like
connected to Tokyo.
- Close to Tokyo.
- So it wasn't difficult.
- Going into Tokyo,
there was like different trains
that we could get to go into Tokyo.
So, we could like either
take like the rapid train,
which takes like 20 minutes or something
to get into central Tokyo.
But like the rapid train is like,
only comes once an hour.
- It was a Unicorn.
Now there's a commuter rapid.
- Oh, the commuter rapid.
- There's two, there's the
local rapid, commuter rapid.
The local stops every spot obviously.
The rapid stops like, I'd say half.
- People in Japan are definitely
gonna figure that out, where we are.
- Maybe, Oh really think so?
- Yeah because the commuter
rapid is like one train line.
- Oh really, there is a few stops
that it goes to that we could live at.
- I think people in Japan now figured out,
"Oh, it's definitely that line,"
that they were wining about.
- Good thing we don't live there anymore.
- Yeah good thing we don't
(Garnt laughs)
live there anymore.
So there you go.
(crew murmuring)
(Garnt laughs)
There's only one train line.
There's only Saikyō Line that's still
(background noise drowns out other sounds)
I'm just gonna say it because
there's only one line.
- Joey, Joey.
- Well, they wouldn't know the exact stop.
- Yeah, yeah. That's fine, that's fine.
- Okay there's two
lines in Saitama though,
that you can get, the
Keiō Tokyo and the Saikyo.
Keiō Tokyo sucks, stops every stop.
It takes like 10 hours to get anywhere.
There's like two lines.
One of them actually gets you places.
The other one, it literally
takes like two hours
to go from like the...
- It's because Keiō Tokyo
like from start to finish,
goes through full prefectures.
- Yeah it's crazy.
- Yeah it's nuts.
- And then like where we used to live,
like if we could plan
going into Tokyo right?
'Cause you can plan to go this time,
to get the commuter rapid.
It's a fast train.
But my God! Going back
it was such a pain right?
- Seibu-Shinjuku at like
11 was like nightmare.
- [Joey and Garnt] Yeah.
- 'Cause you'll never
get the commuter rapid.
You will never get like the
rapid. It's always the local.
And then suddenly a 20 minute
commute turns into an hour,
on the local train.
It was like the first
few times I was like,
okay, I okay, I can do this.
And then afterwards,
especially when we started
coming to the office,
where we moved office.
I wanted to move a lot closer.
- The first year didn't bother me much.
I didn't really care much that it got to.
But yeah I'm glad we moved.
I mean, I liked where we lived actually.
It was a nice area.
- [Garnt] Yeah, it was a really nice area.
- It's just too far.
(Connor chuckles)
And I won't lie, the Uber
Eats selection was shocking.
(Joey laughs)
You pretty much,
you had one option for every cuisine.
So it was like, if the Thai place was bad,
which luckily it wasn't.
- The Thai place there
was like the banger.
- Okay, the Thai place
was like the best place,
but like the...
All right Chris current Thai right.
(Joey laughs)
- He's like, "If it's not
Michelin, I ain't having it."
- There was like no
good Italian food that
delivered, which was like...
- I feel like there was.
- This is the most
privileged fuckin thing.
I don't care, I love
Italian food and I love
getting that pasta.
- "I don't know if you
"heard of Domino's?"
(Group laughs)
- It's pretty Italian, if
you know what I'm saying.
- They do pizza?
- They do pizza, and pasta.
- There was one place, but it
was ridiculously expensive.
- For me the biggest
thing that was missing,
Uber Eats selection was healthy options.
- Oh yeah there was like,
no like salad or anything.
- Like if you wanted healthy foods,
you needed to cook it yourself.
And a lot of the times,
a lot of the times I wanted
to eat healthy and then like,
I would get back from work,
and then the day would be over.
- This is the most first
world problems we have.
- "God forbid I chop bubble
lettuce in my own home?"
- We be like the Uber Eats
selection was rather poor.
(Garnt laughs)
This is like pre-oligarch,
like levels of water.
- I used to just go out a lot to eat.
Just because when I did
move into my previous place,
I saw the Uber Eats options.
It was like, are you? Fuck
that! I'm just gonna go out.
- But you're busy enough.
But also you were a lot closer
to the places than I was so.
- Yeah I guess so.
- But It was like nothing
near me news.
- It was nice though.
Like that area was super
nice to walk around in.
- Yes, I do miss the area.
'Cause like, I feel like I only started
to really walk around and explore
when I was deciding whether
I should move or not.
(Garnt laughs)
- Right, right.
- And I was just like,
oh, there's a lot of cool places,
a lot cool cafes and restaurants
that I just didn't notice before,
'cause I'd never bothered
exploring the area
and they didn't show up in Uber Eats.
So how could I discover them?
- [Joey] Yeah exactly.
- And yeah, like I feel
like there's a lot of
small local places that I miss now.
But I'm also happy
to be in a more convenient area
and being outside that time.
- I'm just happy, we've all moved into
much, much bigger and nicer places now.
And like as good as our
previous places were,
I think, especially
after we got this office,
I think it was definitely
time for an upgrade
in our personal lives as well.
- Yeah, I mean I've said this before,
but I was happy with my place
and I was very lucky to find the place
that I have moved into.
But I was still pretty
happy with my place.
So, to me it's definitely
an upgrade, but it's like,
it's like a natural progression to me.
And I feel like there are some things
that I've definitely
progressed in, in like 2021.
And then there's some
things that I feel like
I've probably regressed
in, or stayed the same.
I don't know. It's been
a sort of weird year.
'Cause after 2020, everyone
was just like all right,
ready to like hit the
ground running in 2021.
And then the environment
just didn't allow us
to like hit the ground running.
- [Group] Yeah, yeah.
- It was like, I remember like,
I think for a lot of 2021,
like I can say this now
because I think before
going back to England,
I was definitely burnt out.
- I was the same.
- I'm say the same, like
I was definitely burnt out
and everyone's just like,
"Oh, why didn't you take a holiday?
"Why didn't you take some time off
"to just look after your mental
health and all that stuff."
And what I will say was,
there was nothing that I could do.
(Garnt chuckles)
There was nothing that I wanted to do.
'Cause what I wanted to do was,
see family, see friends,
back home, see people...
- Two years is a long time man.
- Two years is a very long time.
And that was like my reset right?
So, before that, like I
was definitely burnt out.
And I kind of just dealt with it
by just trying to fill up my schedule.
And kinda kind of just like ignoring it.
And I didn't fully realize that
until I went back to England,
and I just had nothing on my schedule.
And I just realized,
holy shit! This is really refreshing.
I'm getting a lot of ideas.
And I wanna go back to work now.
- I'm not doing a single thing.
(Garnt chuckles)
- Is this what it's like to have a break.
Have a proper break?
- This is what it's like to have a life.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
To just not do anything.
- Yeah. So, I mean, that's kind of like
what has been hardest in 2021.
'Cause 2020 was like, was a year where
the entire world was flagged.
2021 was like, me waiting for the world
to get back to normal.
And it's finally looking like
it is going to get back to normal now.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Fingers crossed, touch wood.
- Are you boys happy with your
YouTube channel this year?
- Yeah.
(Group chuckles)
- Which one Joey, which one?
- Both, both.
- I love it 'cause 2021 is the year that
Joey finally became an AniTuber.
- Yeah. Not on the Anime Man channel.
- Just (laughs) not on
the Anime Man channel.
- Yeah I have,
(Joey laughs)
I told Garnt about it
but 'cause I've been uploading
a lot more on my second channel now,
and I'll be making a
lot more Anime content
on my second channel
now that I have a playlist
called Actual Anime Content.
(Group laughs)
Just to poke fun, but like yeah I dunno.
I'm very harsh on myself when it comes
to my YouTube channel and my
content and stuff like that.
So like, I'm obviously proud
of all the videos I
upload, on both channels.
- Otherwise I wouldn't upload it at all.
But I'm definitely...
- I'm fuckin not proud of all of them.
(Connor laughs)
- All right.
But like, I'm definitely
one of those people
that's like, after a week,
of that like honeymoon period,
I'm like yeah,
could have done better on that video.
I'll do better on the next one.
And then I try and do it,
and I keep thinking I'm
going in the right direction.
Then I'm just like...
At the end of it I look back at all of it.
I'm like, yeah like, 5% of it was okay.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- The 95% could have used a bit of work
But I think, like I have
like plans for next year,
for what I wanna do with my shit.
But like, I dunno,
it's gonna be scary because
it's gonna be a lot different,
to like pretty much everything
I've established up until this point so...
See how it goes,
but I guess that's why we
have Trash Taste for right?
Like as a fail safe almost or a...
Not so much a fail safe, but like,
'cause I guess like...
- [Garnt] A safety net.
- Yeah, like a safety net I guess,
because when we started again,
it was like when we started
Trash Taste, we were like,
"Oh yeah, this will be
like a nice side project
"for us to do."
And like we could do
all sorts of cool things
on the sideline while we
focus on our main content.
But now it's like well,
we're like 1.1 million
subs or something.
- That's crazy.
- Insane on the main channel.
- Fuckin insane
Thank you again by the way guys.
Now it's like pretty much
become like the main basket now.
And our main channels,
and our side channels,
and whatever else that we
do outside of Trash Taste
has become the safety net almost.
- I don't know Trash Taste has become
like almost the number one priority.
It is the number one priority.
- [Joey] It is the number one priority.
- When we need to schedule a recording,
that's getting done before
any of my fuckin videos.
Or any of my scripts in man.
- Yeah exactly.
(Group laughs)
- Exactly. So it's like, definitely,
'cause like we do have like lots of
exciting plans for Trash
Taste obviously next year,
which obviously can't tell you
but look forward to it.
- Yeah I definitely plan
my working week around Trash Taste.
Not the other way round.
- [Joey & Connor] Yeah.
- And I think just like that right?
Like that mentality is
already just telling off.
Like, this is our main stick now.
- But also when I think because
all three of us are involved,
I guess we probably pay more respect
to the scheduling of Trash Taste.
It's all right well.
- Yeah, definitely.
- If I fuck over my own channel,
that's my own problem.
(Joey laughs)
But if I fuck over the
scheduling with Trash Taste,
it's like a burden to everyone.
And we have people who turn up
to help us with Trash Taste.
When I fuck around doing
a Monkey Tier List on my own channel,
if I don't do that,
it's on me and that's it right?
No else is still looking.
- I think that that's like,
I guess like going back to the whole,
like getting a personal assistant,
or like getting a team,
to help behind the scenes of like
my main channel and stuff like that.
I think that's the one
thing I'm scared of,
which is like, I'm gonna
feel more pressure now
to deliver on my main channel,
because now it's not just
me that I'm taking care of.
It's I'm taking care of
a personal assistant,
or like an editor, or a
manager, or whoever right.
There's like multiple people's
livelihoods at stake right.
That's really the only thing
I guess that's stopped me
from personally getting
a personal assistant.
- #No one's taught them.
Maybe they'll realize
that I'm fuckin stupid.
I don't know. (laughs)
They be like why am I helping you?
It is a lost 'cause.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
- No, like for me,
I think the biggest change
for me this year is,
I guess I've been really
trying to figure out,
not what I want to do
but how I want to do it.
- I feel like you said this
last year and the year before.
(Connor and Joey laughs)
Is that okay if we just say...
- Did I say this last year?
- You definitely said this last year.
- Yeah, because I think
this year has been the year
where I've really like knuckled down
to try to really start
thinking of my main channel,
as like content, as a job that
I have to like break down,
and like actually be strict
on how long it takes to
like make a video because...
- You're right, you can't
taking months to make one video.
- No, I mean like, it's like,
because I think one big
thing that has changed
since joining Trash Taste right?
Is that for better or worse.
My content upload schedule
as compared to you're guys right?
And especially like seeing how
you're guys' content is made.
Like not saying like,
obviously I'm not saying like,
anyone's content is better or worse.
It's just like,
I've kind of realized that,
I want to upload as much as you guys,
but with the workflow of my solid content,
I've tried to like cut as
many, many corners as I can.
And there is like...
There is just too many bottlenecks
that I can't do to like...
Like I've reached max productivity
that I can reach with my channel.
And before last year I was like,
"I can improve, I can do better.
"I can do like three videos
a month, and Trash Taste."
And now I've come to realize that,
not only is that setting the
wrong expectations for me,
to feel like I can do it.
And I feel bad if I don't do it,
but it also like sets
the wrong expectations
for the viewer as well.
'Cause if the viewer is
expecting me to upload
that many videos a month
and I kind of like,
I kind of keep doing that,
then that's just gonna be unsustainable.
And I'm just gonna burn out,
which I did do this
year, but that's like...
I didn't burn out because
I was putting myself
through too much work,
I burnt out because of
the world situation.
But I've just realized
that, I need to like,
I need to make a schedule,
which is sustainable.
And unfortunately, it's
for better or worse.
Like, my upload schedule does
get compared to your guys.
But it's like, I've come to realize
to not feel guilty about that anymore.
- No, when I make jokes about
it. I don't give a shit.
I don't think it is...
- Just a little bit of fun, yeah.
- I also don't like,
I've never considered,
I don't think me or Joey
have ever thought that
your channel, or your content and channel
is comparable to ours in any way.
Like I don't think one upload
is equal to one upload on...
- No, no and not.
- No, definitely not.
- I guess it's like forced
me to like really break down
a workflow to like the video right?
Because like, how long would it take...
How long does it take you
guys like make one video,
like hour wise, would you say?
- That varies.
- Yeah that varies correct.
- It can be literally like two hours
or like a hundred.
- [Joey and Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- There's some videos that like,
even one now that's really,
it's like a really big
video I've been working on
that I've been wanting to
do for a very long time.
- A lot of moving pieces, and a lot of,
a lot of, a lot of, a lot of edits,
and a lot of footage to go through.
But that, no matter,
even if I put like a
month's worth of like,
let's say if you just took
the hours I put into it,
let's say it's like just
a full working month
of hours into one video.
- It doesn't fuckin matter
'cause I gotta upload
the week after anyway.
So it so unlike it.
- Yeah exactly.
- But then maybe the week after
will be something that took me two hours.
So, it's kind of,
you kind of have to juggle it
but also not make it look
like all these videos
are like completely different quality.
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
- Which is why I kind of just realized.
Okay, the only way I can make my videos
not seem drastically like different
in feeling, theme, quality, production,
is to just have,
I guess, me being an
idiot, and my personality
being like the focal point.
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
- Or at least a main aspect of the video.
- Yeah. So like I had
to break down for like,
let's say like the fastest video...
- So I had to breakdown for this?
- So, I had to break down
(Connor and Joey laughing)
my video making process.
Like the fastest video you can make
is like say in like
two, three hours right?
Let's say you like,
you needed to get a video out.
So I felt like a few times
where I just need to
get a video out right?
- That's the time on my
end, not including editing.
- [Joey and Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So like for me,
like I need to like
pencil in and let's say,
I'm doing a video about an Anime right?
So I have to pencil in hours,
like a round about a day,
to watch the Anime.
Which is like,
assuming it's like a
season of Anime right?
And then let's say,
two days for scripting,
which is like one day
for the actual script.
One day it's like finish the script
and actually make it like a good script.
And, and so that's
already three days right.
And then I have to have like,
two hours or so,
two hours for like the
recording of the script.
And then I send that off.
So that's like, on my end,
three and a half days already,
to be sent off to the editor.
Now the editor edits it and
he has to send it back to me.
And I have to do like
the finishing touches,
uploads, and finishing touches,
upload, thumbnail, and title,
which if I'm really lucky
would take half a day.
So that's like four days basically,
of workflow from beginning to end.
And that's if I'm fully productive
and nothing goes wrong right?
That's the fastest I can make a video.
- All of you assume that
I don't procrastinate.
(Joey laughs)
- Now so that's
four days in a week.
Trash Taste is one day in a week right?
I also want weekends as well.
(Garnt laughs)
- Oh now you're just wishful thinking.
You are at that point
- You are weak Garnt.
- Beggars can't be choosers.
- I've realized like in my previous years,
when I've been able to
do three videos a month,
I've been able to do three
videos a month and Trash Taste,
because I've just worked on weekends.
And I've just realized
I kind of want weekends.
And I kind of also wanna do
other things like stream,
and like maybe focus on
some side projects as well.
And I've just realized,
I'm trying to put too much on myself.
And there's like,
with the type of video I'm making,
if there's no way I can
make this video faster
than the way I'm making it,
and people will say well,
"Why don't you become like a
personality based channel?"
Like you guys where you can
do different kinds of content
that is more focused on any personality.
And I've played around with that.
And then I've just realized,
no I kind of like enjoy what I do.
I like scripting I've...
I've already got Trash Taste.
I have a channel
that is based around my
personality so called.
(Connor laughs)
And so, I've just like,
I've just realized that,
my main channel is always
going to be a max cap,
two uploads a month.
If I'm lucky three uploads a month.
And I'm not going to feel
guilty if I don't make that.
If it's one upload a month
because I'm traveling or
because I'm on holiday,
that's what you're getting.
And like, I guess this is a
message to you guys as well,
which is I know the imagery is just like,
oh, Garnt is a lazy bum
(Joey & Connor laughing)
who doesn't upload that much.
But trust me, I am
working at full capacity
and you guys are getting
two uploads a month,
maybe one upload a month,
if I'm busy that month.
But, that is me at max capacity.
And I'm not going to try to pretend
that anything else is that.
- I honestly never saw a problem.
Like, as much as I like,
poking fun of it or whatever,
in episodes and stuff like that.
I honestly never saw a problem
with your upload schedule.
Because again like,
I know how much work goes into the content
that you make specifically.
Like you say you take two
days to make a script.
I sometimes take like
a week to make a script
'cause I'm nowhere near
as good as making a script as you are.
- The two-day script
happened this year. (laughs)
- Oh yeah right.
- Before it would take like,
maybe like three days or four days before.
- I can't script.
- But I feel the more scripting you do,
the better you get at it
because you understand,
the basics of how to
get a script down right?
Like, I remember the first script
I wrote took me fuckin forever
because I was like,
how do you write jokes?
I've never written a joke down in my life
and performed it off of a script right?
So, it's like yeah.
So, I would see like your upload schedule
and then I would see your videos.
And I would think to myself,
all right if I were to make this video,
how long would it take for me?
- And then I think to myself,
yeah, it'd probably take even longer
than it probably took Garnt right?
And that's why I've never really seen
a problem with your upload schedule.
If anything I think like...
I'm honestly even thinking
like for next year,
I'm thinking to maybe go to like
something similar to your
upload schedule as well
because I wanna put,
because I think this year,
the thing that's changed
with my channel is that like,
I've definitely upped my
quality of content or like,
I've upped the bar of
the minimum standard that
a video should be.
And that has resulted in videos,
not only taking longer to
make and to edit for Mudan
but also it's taken longer
to prepare just in general.
- So it's like right now,
especially these last couple of months
that I've been in like a
little bit of a burnout.
I've noticed that like,
one week or a week is
starting to get tough.
- I actually forgot I had
to upload the other day.
- Yeah right.
- I was so busy.
- I mean especially with us two.
- Legitimately I just
forgot to upload the video.
And then the day...
It was like midnight and I was like,
oh, I could upload it right now
'cause it was supposed
to go up in three hours.
But I had to wake up at
4:00 am to do a call.
So I was like fuck this.
I need like these three
hours of sleep I'm getting.
- [Joey and Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Right so, but it's like,
especially with us two
now that we've like put more effort
into our second channels as well right?
- And on top of Trash Taste every week,
and then Trash Taste After
Dark every week right?
Like, that's already so
much shit on my plate,
that I realize like,
oh, if I continue this,
once a week schedule
or if I kind of lock myself
into this once a week schedule.
I'm either gonna completely burn out.
I'm either just gonna
be so fuckin exhausted
that I can't do anything.
Or, worst case scenario both.
And the quality of my videos
is just naturally gonna go down.
- I've been toying with the idea of
just not uploading all January.
Doing the classic YouTuber move.
- Oh yeah.
- I was like, I kind of wanna like
just do streaming all month.
So, and I thought
January is the best month
because that's when you get like...
- [Garnt] zero Ad revenue.
- You get zero Ad revenue.
And that's the YouTuber
month that everyone takes off
'cause they aren't getting much money.
(Connor laughs)
- Yeah, yeah.
- But I was like,
I do actually wanna try doing
like streams full month,
see how it goes and then,
have more of a consistent
schedule with that.
'Cause I feel like I've
invested a lot in the streaming,
but I'm still like in compared
to other people who have
full-time streamers,
I'm nowhere near as consistent.
And I think that's one thing that's like,
is a detriment to that,
'cause people always complain like Connor,
"I never know when the
fuck you're gonna stream."
And I'm like, "Yeah, I know."
But that's what I like about it.
(Group chuckles)
I like that I just turn up
and I'm like, all right,
"I'm just gonna stream
for 12 hours now casually,
"let's do it."
- But I think like Trash Taste
has definitely done a good job
with like, to varying
levels, or varying results,
like Trash kind of like gotten us
to kind of look at our main channel stuff
and being like, "I could probably change."
- Is it actually a main channel?
Is it like... (chuckles)
- I just say main channel for
the purpose of main channel.
- I really didn't think
about like the only...
It's weird now.
Old channel.
- It's weird now
- I didn't even think of any
channel as the main channel.
I'm just like, I just make shit.
Some of it has priority
over the other ones.
But it depends week by week,
which one I might prioritize
- Because like, part of the reason
why I've been putting down the...
I've been putting the
same amount of videos
on the main channel now,
which is two videos a month
and I'm not gonna try to do
more because I want to...
- You do two videos a month?
- I thought you did one a month.
- No, I only do one a
month when it's a holiday.
(Joey and Connor mumbling)
So yeah yes, so right now
I'm doing two videos a month.
And I'm putting all my extra time into,
I do also wanna like
make a second channel,
'cause that seems fun.
- It's super fun.
- I see you guys doing it and
I'm just like, you know what,
maybe my main channel doesn't
need to be my top priority.
I've got like the formula
down for my main channel.
And now I just wanna...
I just want this extra
time to do other shit now,
because I was thinking,
'cause I have like a lot of
ideas for like big projects
that can go to my main channel right,
which I am sitting on.
But my God, they're going
to take so much fuckin time.
And I'm like doing these big projects
really takes a lot out of you,
especially when you're also trying
to maintain your consequences
and upload a schedule on
your main channel anyway.
- So, I've kind of come to realize that,
when I really, really feel like
I'm down on YouTube and
I need to work on a video
that I'm really passionate in,
then I'm gonna start doing those.
But for now, like I wanna
do more small, small stuff.
I wanna do more small,
small stuffs with you guys.
- I think the thing for me was I was,
'cause I'm not sitting here saying
that my main channel is
quality by any means.
I think there is some level
of effort that goes into it.
And I mean I'm to harsh on myself.
- Would that not be quality?
I think it's quality.
- There's a certain bar.
- It is quality.
- There's a certain bar that I try to do
on the channel for most videos.
There are some times
like, I did like a fuckin,
which Chris loves to joke about.
My monkey TLS video,
which I just wanted to do,
'cause I thought it was fun.
But it's obviously, it's not,
it's nothing like
exceptional, but in general,
the videos that I have
were quite difficult,
but, sometimes I see someone doing
like a you laugh, you lose challenge.
I'm like, "That's seems fun."
I'd like to do that.
- I'll do it live instead.
I'll do it on the other
channel 'cause it works.
And so, it kinda came to a point where
a lot of fun ideas,
that just weren't big enough,
or weren't exciting enough
to like warrant putting a lot
of time and effort into them.
Just kinda work really
well on the other channel
and it's something I wanted.
- That's what I've noticed.
One. That's why I want a second channel,
because I feel like I have set
a bar of quality on my main channel.
And I've liked tested
uploading videos that
maybe have not had as
much time put into them.
And you do see it in the
view numbers, eventually.
So, that's why I'm just like okay,
let's just keep my main channel
for like the contents.
- [Connor] Big boy videos.
- It's for the big boy videos.
For the videos that my
audience expect of me.
But that doesn't mean you can't do
other things on the second channel.
- [Joey] Yeah. It's like,
there's like so many like,
especially timely things or,
like so many things that perhaps
have nothing to do with the
shit I'm known for right.
That I wanna talk about in the video.
Like, when YouTube brought out their news
that they were gonna get rid
of the dislike button right.
I was like, I wanna talk
about this in a video,
but I can't just put up
a 15 minute Rant of me
on the main channel talking about it.
- All right, so it's like perfect. (claps)
I have a perfect outlet
for random shit like that.
- Do you get the comments of,
I don't watch Trash Taste
anymore, I watch Joey.
- Yeah a lot.
(Group laughs)
I mean that's fine and everything
because it's like,
at the end of the day it's still me right.
So, it's whatever, it's weird right.
'Cause especially this past
like two or three weeks,
I've been uploading a lot
more on the second channel.
And I've just like,
I found myself waking up
and thinking to myself,
all right what should the next video
on the second channel be?
- Yeah not the channel.
- Wait, I haven't mentioned, fuck!
I should probably think
about that one as well right.
- I think because another
big thing as well is,
I feel like, right now
with my main channel,
I've definitely seen the plateau
of just that kind of Anime content.
Like that kind of
Anime content.
- [Joey] Same, same.
- And you know, I do
have like ideas about,
how, I could keep that channel growing,
and grow past the plateau.
But the amount of time and
effort that would take,
to me that would take
too much time and effort
that I just don't have right now.
They'll take giving up
Trash Taste basically,
to make content and rebrand my channel
to a point where
it can grow plus past the plateau
of that kind of energy content right.
- How do you feel about the growth
on your channel, your main ain channel?
- Ah, I mean I'm fine with it
'cause I know like right
now AniTube as it is
has just plateaus, like that's,
we've seen a platton.
If there are any other AniTubers
who would like to prove me
wrong, please, because...
- I'm waiting for that one
person to prove me wrong.
- I'm waiting as well because
I need a kick up my ass and be like,
"Oh, you can go higher okay?"
That's like my motivation 'cause like,
I'm sure you guys are the same way.
It doesn't matter how many
subscribers you have right.
What I find happiness
in is growing something.
Or like making it feel like
I have made progress on something.
So, like I felt way more fulfilled
seeing the progress and
growth on Trash Taste
than I did on my own
channel, for like last year.
And like that's why the
thought of a second channel
excites me way more
than even making big
videos on my own channel.
Because even if I make a big video,
my own channel, which
I'm really passionate in,
I know that there's a certain cap
for like the number of
views that's gonna get.
- And I mean it's already like,
especially with like all
of our main channels,
like it's already at a size
where we're pretty happy with right.
And it's like, it's massive
to a lot of people right.
So it's like, it just
makes more sense that like,
obviously you're gonna
have more excitement,
watering this tiny plant than
watering a giant tree right.
Obviously watching this tiny thing grow
into something bigger is
going to be more fulfilling.
Especially if you're
trying to do something
that you're otherwise
not really known for.
Perhaps it's like content that
you've never tried before,
and stuff like that.
And I think that's why I've been having
so much fun with the second channel,
but like, yeah I dunno like,
my main channel grew as well.
Like I hit 3 million subs
this year, as to you.
- So did I.
(Group laughs)
- Yeah you do as well.
- Go ways and where that.
- It doesn't feel like a probably a lot.
- Yeah right, but like
to me it's like I dunno.
Like I know definitely
past me would look at
some months of my channel's
growth and being like, oh man,
I didn't really grow that much at all.
I think I've just rewired my
brain this year to be like,
if it ain't a negative,
then it's all good dude.
Like, if every day I'm
gaining at least one sub,
I'm completely okay with
that now because it's like...
- I haven't been counseled yet.
- Yeah, exactly.
It's like, if people are still like
looking at my shit and
wanting to come in, cool dude.
My doors are open,
but like I'm not at this
point now where I'm like,
oh fuck, I only made
20,000 subs this month.
I'm slowly dying. It's like...
- [Garnt] Yeah, the channel?
- Yeah I'm like don't trynna say oh no,
I'm just past that point now.
Like I'm much rather put in
the time to like, be like,
oh, I have this tiny second channel.
That I'll wanna grow into something big.
So, let's focus on that kind of thing.
Oh, with like Trash Taste for instance.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Like that's way more exciting for me.
And I think that's why,
at least you and I have had
a lot of fun doing the second stuff right.
Yeah man, it's just like streaming man.
- It's just something new right.
- It's fun.
- Did they just start like
properly streaming this year.
Or did they start last
year? I can't remember.
- It almost feels like you've
been streaming forever.
- Like properly, properly
like consistently,
I think it was this year right.
- It's been more this year
than it was last year.
Well last year, since 2009, no.
When was the chess
tournament? The first one?
- Early 2020.
- [Garnt] Yeah 2020.
- Okay well, 2020 was around
when I started streaming.
And then I think,
yeah this year is probably
when it's growing the most.
I've been a lot more consistent,
been doing a bunch of stuff with that.
Yeah, it's interesting.
I still, occasionally I have people
coming into the Twitch being like,
I had no idea you had a Twitch channel.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Oh yeah, yeah. I have
that every time I started.
- Yeah. I guess it's a
different platform right.
- Yeah it is a different platform.
Is there any changes you guys want to make
going into the next year?
Or just continuing what you're doing now?
- I guess just like, I dunno, for me...
- New Year's resolutions.
YouTuber New Year's resolutions.
- (Joey mimics a lame voice)
I'm gonna hit a million subs
on the second channel.
- That's probably gonna be a point.
'cause when the world is opened up,
I do wanna travel a lot more.
And I actually like have a
bit more of time to relax.
So they'll probably be
appointment uploading
a little bit less.
I'm not really too
bothered about it at all.
- I'm just gonna say it now.
Just expect less uploads on
the main channel I think,
just because for one,
I want to put more effort
into each video now.
I don't wanna like be confined to this
once a week schedule and like...
- You're gonna talk about
what Anime you're not gonna watch.
- No, probably not.
(Garnt and Connor laughs)
If I do it, that'll be
on the second channel
where actual Anime
content exists. Subscribe!
But yeah, I don't know like
at least with the main channel,
like I think, I know what kind of content
I wanna like focus more on,
on the main channel from next year.
But that is definitely gonna force me
to not upload every week.
Just because it's going to be impossible.
- Yeah, I think last year
my New Year's resolution
was to be more productive
and to upload more.
And then as I've just said this year,
I've kind of realized yeah that I tried.
I really did 'cause I
went like a good like,
four months where I had like
three videos a month,
and I'm just like yeah.
- Did you really.
- Yeah I'm just like...
- That was before he went to the UK,
it was like pretty consistent.
- It was so really, fuck!
- You don't watch Gigguk?
(Joey laughing)
- I do but I couldn't be sure.
- It was literally just
before the office move.
And then it took like...
- Oh really.
- Fuckin three weeks
for the office move.
- Oh Joey.
- I mean it was around the same time.
So it was like the first half of the year.
And then I realized,
okay, my resolution
was just unsustainable.
And I'm like, I've accepted that.
- So, my New Year's resolution is,
I wanna do more collabs.
And, it's not gonna be
on the main channel,
which is why I wanna focus
more on another channel.
Because I've kinda realized
collabs just don't work for the dynamic
on my main channel.
That's there's...
- Why What'd you mean,
come to my all collab.
All collab, remember that one?
- That one?
- The one collab.
- That legendary club?
- That one that was skit?
- Okay. That was a long time.
- That was like three, four years.
- Come on you used me
out of the bustle a lot.
(Garnt laughs)
- I mean 'cause like I wanna do less,
something that's like not scripted,
and I'd feel like,
anything I scripted in collabs.
Anything I do on my main
channel has to be scripted.
So that, that video
was obviously scripted.
- I also just want like more time
to work on like side projects.
- I wanna do a week long
livestream at least at some point.
I'll do it at some point.
- Good luck with alvra.
- I'll do it at some
point. I did three days.
Just double them.
- That's just (chuckles) double yeah.
- It was double.
- Did that not like break you?
- No.
- Three days will like
easily break me off like...
- It is three hours for me.
- I think I made a mistake
of shouting during one game.
Too much getting angry.
And it fucked my throat
for like the next day.
And then obviously it wasn't
having any time to heal
'cause I was talking all day.
And so that was a rocky mistake.
If I do it again, I'm
not gonna shout as much.
(Joey laughs)
Not as angrily.
But, actually the
sleeping in that shit bed
was kind of uncomfortable.
I didn't really get good
sleep. That was one thing.
- No yeah, I wouldn't either.
- I wouldn't with a fuckin rave.
- If I had thousands of people...
- Yeah with a fuckin rave
going on in the background as well.
- The bed sucked.
I'd probably just do one night
where I'd just go and
sleep in my nice bed,
and I'm like, "I'm rested
boys, let's get it. Let's go.
"Come on. Marscube streaming."
- Yeah, yeah.
I dunno. I wanna do that at some point.
It's not a wonder.
- Yeah and I mean like,
I guess like in the case with like
Trash Taste as well,
like because you know,
we're that the world is hopefully
gonna open up a little more next year.
We're just gonna be really busy
with that shit as well.
- I mean like
the workload for Trash Taste
has been up as well right?
'Cause we don't,
now we stream every
week if you didn't know,
until at least until
Christmas comes along which...
- Trish.tv/trashtastepodcast.
- Which would be around now.
But once the New Year rolls along,
I wanna continue the weekly streams.
- Yeah, I defer, I detour.
- But like, what that means is that
we're basically just recording
another podcast every week.
- We put each have two
Trash Taste's at this point.
(Garnt laughs)
You have the Trash Taste,
and the Trash Taste After Dark.
- Yeah you guys are getting like
five hours of content of which isn't most.
- Which if there wasn't
enough of my schedule already.
There's, there's another thing
to tick off the main channel.
It's another Trash Taste recording.
- I think somebody added up
all the runtime of Trash Taste
and it was longer than like
all of DBC or something.
(Joey laughs)
- I believe that.
- You still rather watch that of DBC.
- The people are like, I've
re-watched episodes there.
And all of them. Oh my God!
- Regarding Trash Taste though.
We figured out earlier
that we've only uploaded
one special this year.
- Oh yeah. Which is the Cycling
Special back in Favorite,
which we filmed the year prior.
- When will "The Figure"
episode count as a special?
- It's kind of year.
- [Garnt] It's like half a special.
- It's like half a mini special yeah.
- [Garnt] I guess it's
a mini special.
- It's a special in nature.
And not a name.
(Garnt laughs)
'Cause we're still
in the office.
- Yeah I mean we had "The Cycling Special"
and then we've had like
some mini specials,
like "The Figure special,"
"The PC build special."
But I guess it truly is like top gear now.
- Where we get like...
[Garnt and Joey] once a year.
- One big special a year,
and very other week is just like
the normal episode.
- We should name
big two specials a year.
That's probably a healthy amount.
- Two yeah, I think two is special amount.
- Yeah well a big portion
of this year was...
- Remember when we first
started doing specials,
we were like, for a year, let's do it.
(Garnt laughs)
All right.
That ain't happening.
- Well, because we had like,
we had just like,
back then we had our main
channel with Trash Taste
and that was it.
- Yeah that was it.
- Now we have our main channel.
You guys are doing your
second channel, streaming,
Trash Taste After Dark.
And then we gotta do to
our specials on top of it.
(Group laughs)
- [Joey] Easy, easy.
- Mudan, Mudan, teach us
how this is done Mudan?
And people wonder why we want assistance.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah right.
I really, I might genuinely
considering it for next year.
I think it's gotten to the
point where I actually will.
It's not a matter of if, I need one,
or if I want one, I actually need one.
Otherwise I think I'm gonna go insane.
- No, I've been trying
to look for one as well.
But I want an assistant who is in Japan,
which is very hard.
Otherwise I'd just like
fuckin fly Eleanor over or something.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But yeah, I am also definitely
looking for an assistant.
(Connor & Joey yawning)
- This episode is sponsored by Manscaped.
- Oh! Ho! Ho! Gentlemen.
The holidays came early.
(Joey celebrates)
Thanks to Manscaped.
(Garnt mimics a woman's voice)
- Hell yeah.
- [Connor] The leading
men's hygiene brand.
Manscaped just launched new products,
including their all-new
ultra premium TM body wash
and a two-in-one shampoo and conditioner.
It's time to give yourself
and somebody who needs it.
The gift of beautiful skin, hair and balls
this holiday season.
Go to manscaped.com and
use code "TRASHTASTE,"
for 20% off plus free shipping.
- [Garnt] Inside the
performance package 4.0,
you'll find the signature lawnmower 4.0.
This electric trimmer has
proprietary, advanced
skin-safe technology,
to reduce the cuts on your nuts.
- [Joey] Did you know
it's also waterproof,
so you can use it in the shower.
It's like a gift to your
partner, with less mess.
- [Garnt] It also includes
the crop preserver, and crop reviver,
and Anti-Chafing board deodorant,
moisturizer, and toner.
It's time to keep your north pole feeling,
and smelling fresh.
- Gonna be south.
- This hygiene bottle will also come
with a with pair of Manscaped
TM, Anti-chafing boxes.
That'll keep your junk
feeling fresh all day.
The Perfect Package for
your Perfect Package.
- So you can get 20%
off plus free shipping
with the code "TRASHTASTE"
at manscaped.com.
That's 20% off, and free
shipping on manscaped.com,
by using the code "TRASHTASTE."
Clean up your nuts and
make Santa proud this year.
- Thank you for sponsoring it. Deez nuts!
- You guys had any regrets this year?
- Oh fuck, that's a fuckin question.
(Garnt laughs)
- Just gonna drop
that bombshell.
- That came out of no where.
- Why, have you?
- No.
- Me neither.
- Are you gonna have a rest?
- I'm tryinna think.
That question just came
up on the top of my head.
- I regret not going to the gym more.
- No regards, I dunno.
- I regret not studying Kanji.
(Garnt laughs)
- I do realize that.
- As we found out on
the Trash Taste stream
the other day.
- It would be like that
But no I actually regret
not putting more time into Japanese,
because my Japanese studying
has been like very spotty this year.
I'd be like super into it,
and then like, something would happen
and then like I would take a day off,
and then that would just
like stack onto like
two days and three days.
And then suddenly I'd find like
a month had been taken
off of learning Japanese.
And then like the first few weeks
of me getting back into Japanese
is just like me relearning the shit
that I already knew before.
It's kind of like the
gym in that day right,
where in that way,
where you make your gains,
and then you stop going,
and then when you go back to the gym,
you gotta like,
regain the gains you already had.
And it just feels like
really demotivating.
(gentle upbeat music)
It's like trying
to push through.
(Connor whispers)
- It sucks.
- I really wanna get to the gym more.
But I'm just lazy.
- Are you just lazy, or is it just because
you have got so much
going on in your life now
that you just don't have the time?
- I mean if I really, really,
really wanna go to the gym,
I could make time.
You know what I mean?
But it's not something that I
enjoy as much as other stuff.
But I really do wanna go more.
Yeah. Or some days after I've like,
after I've been, you
hurt for the next day.
And then the day after that,
I'm like not great feeling 100%,
but it's the only time
that we can have time,
but I'm like oh shit.
Fuck maybe I'll go, maybe I won't.
It's tough. It's tough.
It's really annoying.
I don't know.
My schedule was a lot more unflexible now.
So, I think I have times to go.
It's just a lot difficult.
A lot more difficult to get it in,
in the way I wanted it to.
- Yeah because I think.
Because you just have so much
more shit going on right.
So like even if you are at
the gym, it's like, oh fuck!
You're just thinking of all the stuff
that you could be doing otherwise.
And it just feels better.
- I travel a lot more videos as well now.
So, that takes stuff away.
- It feels weird there was a point where
"The Seadog channel" was just
you inside filming videos.
And now that Fifty video
that is not outside.
I'm just like, I'm kinda
slacking back, kinda slacking.
(Group laughs)
- "Is that honey."
- This is what I'm worried about.
So I'm like fuck all right.
So let's say, I wanna get
back to the UK at some point.
Where the fuck I'm I
gonna do on my channel?
Everyone's gonna be like,
"Why isn't he outside?"
Like so what is it I fuckin do
in the UK outside?
- Just go to Weather Sprints.
(Garnt laughs)
- fuckin off.
I'd just try every pint
in Weather Sprints.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's not a bad idea actually.
(Group laughs)
I'd watch that.
- I was afraid you'd
try every meal deal at Tesco.
- Right, I'd do that too.
(Garnt laughs)
I've already tried them all,
but I'll prevent like I haven't.
- Do it on video.
- I don't even know what I would do.
Like, I'd basically be like
shitty Tom Scott at that point,
(Group laughs)
"This is a house, where they
get water through a well.
"It's really old and stuff."
That's like the UK.
We don't have anything interesting.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
We only have like really
old quirky stuff in the UK.
We don't have anything modern
that's like fuckin insane.
- Yeah I guess that's why
I want to travel south side the UK.
It's got some interesting stuff.
- I generally really
don't know what I would do
with my main channel content
if I ever moved back to the UK.
Don't worry I don't have plans to...
- [Garnt and Joey] It's not
happening any time soon.
- These boys keep me
hostage, I'm joking. (laughs)
I don't know what I would do, I mean I...
- This cheque titled "Trash
Taste" keeps me hostage.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- It's very enticing.
- That's the thing that's weird.
Having, like having a specific spot
I need to be in every week, like a job.
And when we have to take holidays now,
we have to tell the boys,
and put in our holiday time.
(Joey laughs)
To be like,
"Hey, I'm going to be away for this week."
- Yeah, I mean we could just like...
- Put in the hours ahead of time.
- Right, yeah yeah.
- We could just like, not
have Trash Tastes some weeks,
but then also it's like, why? Why not?
We can easily just make it every week.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I'm not a fan of like the whole,
not uploading on holidays.
'Cause I'm like,
I only like some of my audience
celebrates set holidays,
so I don't feel like
it's fair to just be
like, "Oh fuck you guys."
People who don't celebrate
the same holidays as me.
I'm not giving you content, I'm busy.
It's a valid excuse.
I think in some ways, when
you let your busy part,
I also like uploading.
And I like the Trash Taste uploads
every, every, every week no matter what.
It's like no matter how
normal people are doing,
it's like you can expect
that you're gonna get a
Trash Taste every week.
- It's called like comfort food.
- 'Cause I liked that about
channels I watch that.
That like no matter where I am,
even if 'cause sometimes,
maybe Christmas I got some downtime,
for an hour or two, I might watch a video
that's coming out,
that I'm really excited for.
- [Garnt] Yeah exactly.
- I like it, I like it.
- Well, the thing about Christmas right?
It's that okay, so you have,
you have the beginning right.
You wake up early with the family.
You open presents, and
everyone opens their presents.
Everyone's all merry and happy.
So what happens between like
11 o'clock to four o'clock.
- Food and alcohol.
- Food, alcohol and check this out.
You saw this on TV.
- Food comes on at four right?
- What?
- Food comes out about four.
- You don't have like all Christmas lunch.
- I mean like okay.
- Wait, wait, wait, what?
- What's for Christmas lunch?
- Wherever you want.
- Whatever you envisioned
a dinner to be, dude.
- I'm about to have like an all
you can eat buffet for dinner.
You better know that
I'm saving space for
that Christmas dinner.
- Well no I have that buffet at lunch
and then don't have dinner.
- I have both.
- Because during dinner
time I'm busy getting drunk.
- Oh, dinner time, Christmas dinner!
It's like one of the
best meals of the year.
- We don't do that in Australia.
- What do you do in Australia?
- In Australia, we wake up we have,
we open up all the presents or whatever.
- And then by that time
it's around lunchtime.
And then all the family comes over.
You have like kind of a late lunch,
maybe like two, three o'clock type of
like big, big lunch.
Finish at like 5:00 pm.
And then that's when you get
shit-faced with your family.
And by the time dinner time rolls around.
You're not hungry
because your still full
from the massive lunch.
- I think I have lunch and
dinner, Christmas time pig...
- It's like a lunch and dinner.
- For me It's like...
- It's one big meal.
- No it is one big meal.
- I have two big meals.
(Group laughs)
- How can your stomach handle that?
- It's Christmas baby.
The Christmas spirit man.
This is the largest my
stomach by four times.
- The reason we don't
have a Christmas lunch
or I've never heard of anyone
having a Christmas lunch,
is because I'm pretty sure
during Christmas dinner,
you eat enough to like fill
yourself up for a fuckin week.
- Sometimes like you have
friends who can't come to
the dinner or something.
So, we can meet them
for lunch or something.
- You're going out on Christmas Day! What!
- Blasphemy!
- I go to their house.
- What, you don't spend
it with your family?
- No, no. I'll spend the
dinner with my family.
'Cause maybe there's someone who I must...
- You don't spend all
day with your family?
- No, no, not all the
time. Sometimes I do.
It depends on like who I can
see, when and when I can't.
Some people they have like,
they're having a Christmas thing
and I'll go and say hi, I'll turn up,
and then I'll go back and
spend the evening with family.
- So like last time I went
back to Australia, I did that.
Like I spent like a Christmas dinner
with my friend at my friend's
place, like my uni mate.
But I did that the day after
the actual Christmas event.
As like a late Christmas
kind of thing.
- [Garnt] Right, right.
- But like on Christmas day,
if I'm not at home with my family,
then something's wrong in the family.
- If I'm not at home
(laughs) with the family
or we're not going
to another one of our
family's relatives' places.
Then some beef
is going on.
- Something is weird.
- Some of them are friends,
some of them are family.
It's kind of a mix, depends who it is.
- Okay but like my justification
for the Christmas lunch in Australia
is that you have to understand that,
Christmas day is a very nice summer day.
(Connor laughs)
Right so, going outside,
eating a massive thing
by a pool side is
(Connor laughs)
very normal in Australia.
- Yeah, pass me the Turkey,
I'm in the pool right now.
- Yeah, exactly.
- So you don't have a roast?
- No, we do. But outside.
(Garnt laughs)
- It gets cooked with the
sun 'cause it's so hot.
- Yeah, yeah.
- We pop up a whole...
- So you just have a
fuckin barbecue basically.
- I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- Not even, we just go out onto the road
and just pop a whole
chicken on the tarmac.
And then it just cooks
by itself and it's like
( Joey mimics happy voices)
- It's done five minutes.
- No but like, it's like
reazly, like 34°C, 35°C,
like nice summer day right.
And it's like,
you're out on the
balcony with your family.
And you're having a nice roast, or pork,
or whatever it is that
you eat during Christmas.
And we have that during the day
because the sun's out and it feels good.
That's, that's my justification of
why we have one meal at like two o'clock.
I obviously, if it was like...
- That's so alien to me right.
- Obviously it feels
like winter time right?
I'm not gonna go out.
- So, so okay PM right.
- So, as someone who obviously
grew up in Australia
celebrating Christmas that way,
do you have like this Christmas-y feeling,
like what, do you have
a Christmas-y feeling?
Or do you have anything
that gives you a Christmas-y feeling?
- Yeah Christmas-y feeling is when
I'm having a beer at
like 2:00 pm in a pool.
- That could be that's like
any day for Australians Joey.
It is (chuckles) every day Christmas.
(Group laughs)
- Hell yeah it is Dawg!
- Is it like weird
watching Christmas movies.
- We don't watch Christmas movies.
- At all?
- I don't, at least our family doesn't.
- Australians do.
- Did you have like a
Christmas spirit? Like...
(Group laughs)
- Is it like a dating site.
- No, no, no, no.
- Why are you sharp Joey,
tell us where you was at?
- I remember 'cause, when I
live in Thailand, me and Sydney
celebrated Christmas there
for like two or so years.
Every year she'd tell me,
"You know what, the trees are up,
"we've got the Christmas songs on,
"the roasters out."
But it doesn't feel like Christmas.
She says as, as it is like 35°C
and like hot outside.
Just doesn't feel (laughs)
- Turn on the AC.
It doesn't feel like Christmas.
- I know, it just doesn't
feel like Christmas.
- I mean yeah I know, we put
up a tree and everything,
and we decorated it
and we'll put the lights
on it and stuff like that.
But it's also,
I'm in my board shorts and
T-shirt at the same time.
(Group laughs)
- That just doesn't sound festive to me.
- It's like board shorts,
board shorts, T-shirts, Christmas hot.
There's a great photo of me.
Like just with exactly that getup,
standing in front of the Christmas tree,
sweating my nuts off
because it was like 38°C like that.
- So like, is there like
a certain period of time
where you see something,
and you're like,
oh, Christmas is coming up.
'Cause for me, like in England,
it was whenever, the weather would start
getting like really cold.
And then you'd start seeing
Christmas decorations
pop up here and there.
What is it like in Australia?
- It's the same thing.
You see...
- Is it the same?
- Christmas decorations pop up.
But at the same time, it's like oh,
I gotta start taking this jacket off.
(Garnt laughs)
- My God! That's so bizarre.
- That's how we do it.
- Do you get any houses which
like go absolutely mental
with the Christmas decorations?
- Yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
- It is so odd.
- But the problem is because
it's the summertime right?
You can't turn the lights
on until it's like 9:00 pm.
'Cause it's still bright outside.
- I feel so sorry for fuckin Santa Claus.
And like with like a hot red jacket.
- Oh he ain't in a hot red jacket.
He has no shirt on dude.
(Garnt laughs)
- He's in red board shorts.
Usually no shirt, on a surfboard.
- Do you have like snowmen
decoration and shit like that.
- No, no we know actually...
- Does it snow in Australia?
- In some parts it does yes.
So in Canberra it does.
But not where I'm from no.
Not at all.
It doesn't get cold enough.
It's like the coldest it'll
get maybe it's like 10°C.
- Yeah yeah, but again like
that happens in July
for us, not Christmas.
(Joey laughs)
- That's strange.
- What's Christmas for you Connor?
- What'd you mean?
- What's your Christmas spirit?
- I'm I being interrogated
for my Christmas?
- Yes, yeah come on.
What is your Christmas?
- His Christmas is
not spending the whole
day with his family.
- I like spending the day with my family.
- Is Christmas like a special day for you?
Not, not like, does it
mean something to you,
but like, you know what I mean
where it's just like, it's
Christmas just like...
- The day, I'm indifferent towards.
I don't feel anything
particular on the day.
I like spending, It's a good,
I like the idea of spending
time with the family.
I shut up, fuck yourself Mark
Zuckerberg right now, don't I?
(Joey laughs)
- "I like human activity.
"I like seeing people,
"on the day of the 25th."
- "I'm cooking a skillet."
- "With sweet barbecue rice."
(Group laughs)
- Sorry, but Mark Zuckerberg meme's are...
- I love that meme.
- To me it's like...
I dunno I like watching the
Christmas movies. They're fun.
I like the jingle all the way.
That's my favorite one.
- Jingle all the way. What's that one?
- It's where Arnold Schwarzenegger
tries to buy that figure for his kid.
- Oh, I didn't know
the name of that movie.
- I love that movie.
That movie is so good.
That's like my favorite Christmas movie.
Yeah I dunno.
I like Christmas Eve a lot
as well actually with my family.
'Cause everyone's kinda like,
everyone's trynna warm up.
Everyone's kind of like getting the...
Yeah getting that family vibe yeah.
- 'Cause Christmas Eve
for us is a normal day.
- We don't do anything special.
- Cause you see because were nine.
- We kinda like all,
kinda like talk.
Watch TV or drink. Have a nice meal.
- 'Cause we don't talk otherwise.
(Group laughs)
- Pretty much.
Not as like a collective family unit.
- All right, all right.
- I'll talk to my mom and dad
or then I'll go somewhere.
And then my brother will
tell, you know what I mean?
Like it's never like the
whole units together.
Even now because, me and my family,
all of us live in...
Me and my brothers all
live in different areas.
My brother's gonna go
to Canada now as well.
- Sure.
- So, it's gonna be even harder
to get everyone in the same place.
- I was the difficult one
because I was on the
other side of the world,
but now Evans is gonna
be the difficult one.
So, hopefully I'll get to see.
'Cause I didn't get to
see my older brother
when I went back to the UK.
- [Garnt] Oh, okay.
- 'Cause he was busy doing
stuff in Scotland I think, or something.
- You going back this year?
- Well the Christmas this year? No.
- Okay.
- I don't wanna deal with travel again.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- I feel that.
- I lost enough in my lifetime worth,
but 'cause you didn't go to America
to see Sidney's family right?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- So I guess that's fair enough.
I don't have anything like that.
So, I saw my family.
They got to see me.
I'm like I'll see you next year.
(Group laughs)
I'll probably go back
at some point in April or
something and see them again.
- Was it your parents that said that
they would probably never come to Japan?
(soft upbeat music)
- No.
- Why is that?
- No, no, no. They never said that.
- They wanna go to Japan.
- Why not next time
when the country opens up they come here.
- Oh yeah maybe that too.
- 'Cause I don't think, they
haven't come to Japan before
have they?
- No, no, no.
- My parents really wanna
come to Japan as well.
- I bought them, my Christmas
present was flights for them.
- Oh hell yeah.
- Last year.
(Group laughs)
- Oh, well you go there.
- Do Christmas presents rollover?
(Group laughs)
- I'm like what?
- You haven't redeemed it yet so?
- I got my own man fine.
- It's sitting there, waiting.
- So, I know they want to,
they really, really want to.
I know that they've, I've
really sold them on the idea.
When I first moved here,
they weren't too hyped on it
but after they've watched,
after I moved here,
they kind of watched a
lot more stuff about it
and they're really excited to come.
Which is great because I can't wait
to see how utterly confused they are.
(Joey chuckles)
But yeah now I'm really
excited for them to come over.
And yeah that'll be fun.
- When was the last time
you did spend Christmas
with your family then.
it must been in a while right?
- The one before Japan.
So, 2019 I was in Japan right?
- Yes.
- 2019 Christmas then.
- Damn!
- That's must been a long time man.
- Okay so yeah,
fuck, fuck man.
- It's three years bro.
- Shit.
- Yeah, three years ago.
'Cause the first Christmas,
I'd just moved to Japan in October
and I was kinda settling in.
So I was like I won't come back,
I'll come back next year, Next Christmas.
That didn't happen.
And then they didn't come
by this Christmas either.
- Do you guys ever cook for Christmas?
Or who does the cooking for Christmas?
- My dad.
- My dad yeah.
- 'Cause it's like.
- Spends like 12 hours the day before.
- My dad spends like two days.
- So like what I've always wondered is,
when does the torch get passed over right?
(chuckles)
- When you got your own kids Garnt,
(Garnt laughs)
'cause you have no choice.
- Hopefully not for a while.
'Cause I need a lot of catching up to do.
- 'Cause yeah I mean,
yeah I've started cooking
my own roast as well.
And I'm just like,
I kinda like how my roast cooked
but I don't think it's
as good as my mom's yet.
But I'm just like,
I'm gunning for it eventually.
But I also...
- [Connor] Gunning for the title.
- Also I don't know when in my life
I want to like spend my entire day cooking
because when you cook
a Christmas day...
- Never.
- You're just like, as a kid,
you have comfort in knowing,
that's like the parent's job
to like deal with.
You're out here having
fun with your family.
They're out there just
cooking and all that shit
for an entire day.
And I'm just like,
when is that gonna be my job.
I'm kind of dreading that.
- When a little baby man
is appeasing your life,
I guess that's,
(Garnt laughs)
that's when you can start.
- Joey don't lie, you're
just gonna make Aki do it.
- You gonna be like, honey, honey.
- I mean, every Thanksgiving,
she spends like an
entire day cooking food.
And I'm just like,
oh fuck that.
(Group laughs)
I'm not dong that,
are you kidding me.
- Here to enjoy the fruits of her labor.
- Exactly I get to just
enjoy the food right.
So, yeah I dunno.
Like I've been thinking that too.
'Cause like every time,
'cause I guarantee when
I go back for Christmas,
which I will be by the
time this comes out.
My dad is gonna force me.
It'd be like, "Son, it's
time you learnt the way."
- No, no, no. He's gonna
be in the other room.
He's gonna email you, "Dear son..."
- Yeah, yeah, "Dear son."
- He's gonna leave a YouTube comment.
"Dear son come
in the next room."
- Yeah in my last video,
"Hey son help me with the roast."
(Group laughs)
Yeah but like,
every time I do go back home,
'cause he cooks every night.
- Right.
- You've gotta learn
the family recipe right.
- Yeah right and like I've learned
some of recipes.
- Wait what's your
dad's like specialty?
- My dad's specialty?
My dad's specialty is Moroccan chicken.
- Wow! That seems Nice.
- So, he bought like this,
like proper, like Moroccan,
like a pot type of thing
that has like the kind
of funnel lead on it,
which is like apparently
what they use in Morocco.
Please correct me if I'm wrong about that.
But yeah, it's like
spiced Moroccan chicken,
dates and lemons.
- Do they sound bomb.
- It's so good.
- I'm definitely gonna get them
to make that when I go back home.
But it also takes like six hours to make.
And I'm like,
I mean I love to have that.
Yeah every week in my house,
but I also don't wanna
invest in a fuckin pot,
let alone spend six
hours cooking this thing.
- That just means you haven't reached
that point in life yet.
When you settle down in a house
you're were just like...
Maybe I have some spare
time to start a hobby.
Maybe I should...
- Yeah.
- 'Cause there are some like kitchen ware,
which you never use,
apart for like that one event in the year.
(Group laughs)
When you're like a
teenager, you're just like,
why would I need this thing?
This is just taking up space right.
I hardly have any space
in my kitchen as it is.
But now especially
moving into my new house,
I'm just like,
I remember going to Connor's
house and I'm just like,
oh Connor this cutlery.
It feels good. It feels good Connor God!
This isn't Daiso cutlery.
- I bought IKEA's finest.
(Garnt laughs)
- I did actually feel a little bit
like when I helped Aki
last year for Thanksgiving.
And she made like a Turkey,
like a whole Turkey thing.
'Cause we bought an oven finally.
And the gratifying feeling of me going,
"Honey, bring out the oven tray."
(Group laughs)
was just like,
Aw! This is special day.
We never bring this thing out oh my God!
Aw! This is a special event.
So, I am gonna be like that.
I'm already like that with like tools.
'Cause I've slowly...
- Like which kind of tools?
- Like DIY like...
- Oh okay.
- Like hammers and like all
that kind of shit right.
- I still don't own a
hammer. Not in Japan.
- Wait, what?
- [Garnt] I don't own an hammer.
- Hammers are quite useful.
- Yeah they are quite useful.
- A mallet maybe, like a rubber
mallet is like pretty good.
- I have a rubber mallet so I use it.
- When do you need it?
- I never know
when you need a hammer
- You never know.
- But when you need it,
you're like thank God for
fuckin saying that loud.
- When have you needed one in Japan?
- Like having to like
knock some screws out
of place or something.
- Or nail some things down to like prop,
maybe an artwork up or
something, or you whatever.
- One time my IKEA table was
being annoying with the screw.
I needed a hammer to like push it.
- making like tables and stuff like that.
And you just kinda knock it in.
- It's coming a lot more, I can't tell you
every use I've had for it.
But I remember I've had
multiple times I've been like,
thank God I finally bought a hammer.
- Yeah now that 'cause like,
our current place that we're in,
'cause we have two balconies right.
And like building those balconies,
I was like oh,
I am missing like 90% of essential tools.
So I just went out a day
to like Tokyu Hands or whatever.
And just like binged,
like buying, binge-bought.
(Garnt laughs)
I just like spooshed
on all these tools.
- All that's yours.
- Joey, doesn't binge AnimE anymore.
- [Connor] Binge is tools.
- Binges is hardware.
- Binge is his wallet.
- And like not gonna lie.
That was probably
one of the most fun shopping experiences
I've had in a long time.
- Dou you ever power drill?
- I sure do buddy.
- Oh my God! Do you ever power?
Where can you use a power drill in Japan?
- [Joey] Many places. 'Cause
after while 'cause like,
especially when you're buying furniture,
like when you first move.
So when I was first building my room,
I was like okay,
I have a much bigger room now.
I'm just gonna replace all of like
the desks, and like
shelves and everything,
it was like much bigger, nicer place
that fit the atmosphere right.
So, obviously when you
buy stuff from like IKEA,
or Amazon or whatever,
that don't come in one piece,
you gotta fuckin DIY that shit all right.
- Yeah, I've definitely been feeling that,
for like the past few weeks.
- Don't you hate it?
Twisting the fuckin screwdriver
for 17 hours in the week.
And to the point where
your wrist and your thumb
starts to get sore.
- I do not regret not buying one.
- [Garnt] I guess so.
- I do, I bought my furniture at the Mall,
I regret not buying it.
- So, when I bought like my new bookshelf,
I was still had the screw right.
And then I was like, oh good.
This bookshelf has 50 screws
that I have to screw in.
And they're hard as shit as well.
By the time I finished
like three hours later
my hands were so sore.
So I was like, fuck it
I'm buying a power drill.
Because though I had
another shelf coming in,
built that shit in like 30 minutes cool.
'Cause all I had to do with screw.
(Joey mimics screw sound)
And I was like
(Joey mimics breathes heavily)
technology, is amazing, is incredible.
- Remember when IKEA
selling point was like,
that you get to build your own furniture,
and it's like all convenient and stuff.
And now I'm just like,
I've ordered some furniture off Amazon,
which doesn't need to be built.
And I'm just like, this
is a fuckin godsend.
(Joey and Connor laughing)
They're ahead of the game man.
- Some IKEA products,
I think you can pay them
to assemble in your house.
- Yeah you can, you can.
- Because sometimes IKEA furniture
are actually are really good.
- Yeah.
- Like they have somethings that are
really, really good.
- No IKEA has great furniture.
It's just like...
- Pay me yens to make.
- Yeah.
- Like, especially
moving into a new place.
Making one or two things
that ain't too bad.
That's, that's a fun afternoon.
When you're making like
10 fuckin things in a day,
you're just like,
Can't these things just come pre-built.
- And there are some like,
there some IKEA things where like,
even the way that you have to build,
it is like some kind of autistic feat,
where it's like fuckin algebra one
to get like a fuckin piece in
because it just looks so weird
on the construction thing and so urgh!
- My table kind of broke a little bit,
and one of the screws is missing,
but I should be fine.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah, exactly it happens.
- One of the biggest things,
one of the biggest things
that annoys me is that,
now that I've built so much furniture
in the past few weeks,
I know what kinda packaging
is just like good and optimized.
(Joey laughs)
And what is awful right?
So, like I was building a shelf yesterday.
And like every single screw,
every single compartment,
every single plank,
had like a number sticker on it.
All like came in, came in a bag
that was labeled as a certain number.
And that's great.
Because you look at the
instruction manuals and you see ah!
These number of screw
goes into this number plank.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
I fuckin hate the furniture
that gives you a bag of screws.
And then you get the instruction manuals.
And it gives you like 10
different tonne of screws.
And doesn't tell you...
- And they all look the same.
- IKEA does that.
And it fuckin like blows my mind feeling,
trying to like, it's so fuckin hard
trying to differentiate,
like a screw that's this length,
and a screw that this length
on the instruction module.
And that's just like,
that could be one of 10 screws.
Which screw I'm I supposed to you use.
- The one I hate more than that,
is like when it tells you like,
okay, you have this many screws right?
Like you should have 10 screws.
And so I go to count and I'm
like, why is there 11 screws?
That's not the screw.
And then I realize one is
just there for a spare right.
But they don't tell you it's a spare.
So you just have to assume
that one of them is a spare.
So it's like okay,
because when you finish building it,
and then you realize
and you look down and there's like
three screws left over, you're like...
Well I clearly fucked up somewhere.
- Sometimes in Japan they give you
a pair of gloves with your furniture.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause for some reason you need,
it's to not hurt your hands
I guess when you build it.
They give you like a pair of white gloves.
It's really, I don't know it's cute.
It's really cute, I never wear them
'cause I'm like, why the
fuck would I wear gloves?
(Joey chuckles)
I don't like, they give you
these shitty screwdrivers
and like Allen keys and stuff.
'Cause I feel like It's such a waste.
When I buy like eight things
and I have eight shit screwdrivers
that I have to get rid of.
- I have a cupboard of just
unused Allen keys.
- The shit screwdrivers.
(Joey laughs)
- Like the shitty screwdrivers
are less common than the Allen keys.
- I put my own set of Allen keys.
They are all like perfectly measured,
and they're great, really good quality.
And it's so much better
than using these tiny ones
where you like destroy your Palm,
trynna do that last turn.
- They clearly don't understand
the concept of torque
with some of these.
- They're not long enough.
Dongs ones are really
long, they're really good..
It's so easy to just like turn.
- Unlike the quality of,
for some reasons,
There are some furniture
that the quality of the screws,
it's just like
all over the place.
- Holy shit!
- There's some that are just
like perfectly ingrained.
You can get your stuff in.
- Damascus Steel.
Enhanced Nails.
- And then there are some which I swear
are like pre-sheared.
So like you turn it and it's
like a fuckin ice skate right.
It's just slipping in and out.
And I'm just like, how am I supposed
to get this screw in.
- The worst feeling is when you like,
go for that, you take this
much of the screw is still out,
and you turn it and you feel it shear.
And you look at it, and
it's like already sheared.
You're like fuck!
- It's makes like that horrible.
(Joey mimics screw drivers turning)
- You have to like fully like,
put your full pressure
on it, and not stop.
'Cause if you let go or
It'll like shear it more.
You'll be like fuck I've gotta get this in
before I fuck this up.
- Is everyone keeping on?
(Group laughs)
You know what we're talking about right?
- Just furniture things.
- Just middle-aged guy things.
But yeah I've just noticed that like,
since, having the balcony
and having so many like
new things to build.
I've really enjoyed building furniture.
Like on ironically.
- Joey I'm just buying
furniture I don't need.
- Come into my house
and build my furniture.
That's all I've been doing.
- Honestly dude, I'll happily do it.
It's actually so fun.
I don't know it's like...
- I bet he won't.
If you actually like,
(Garnt laughs)
"Joey, come around this time."
- He says this on camera,
camera toes off yeah.
(Connor mimics Joey)
- "I'm busy that day."
- No, honestly like,
if you like buy me launch or something.
I'll do it.
- All right, okay.
- I'll like dead ass help you out.
- Do you ever like consider
making your own furniture?
Like going proper DIY.
- [Joey] Like buying
the wood and everything.
- Yeah buying the wood.
- I have actually
thought about it.
But at the same to.
- Same to buy what
to make what?
- I dunno, just something, I don't know.
But like, maybe like a table
of fuckin out on the whatever.
- [Garnt] Merge on table.
(Garnt laughs)
- I have thought
about it actually.
I have actually thought about it,
but like yeah because I dunno.
Like I took woodworking like classes
a little bit in like
uni, because it was like
a thing that we had to do.
But like, it's weird because
I'd specifically remember,
I fuckin hated that course.
Like I really did not
like doing like DIY shit.
And it's not until ,
suddenly I have like moved,
and I've got all this like,
I think you know what it is.
It's not that I enjoy DIY,
it's that I like the feeling
of getting new furniture.
(Garnt laughs)
So, that just changed
drastically as opposed.
- But it's like, I think it's well,
it's like it's nice because
I mean you guys have seen me
in this like trance-like state
when I'm building shit around.
Where like I literally just turn on music.
- And I just, I'm in my own world
as I'm like making furniture,
or like whatever it is.
When I'm making something.
I think I like that feeling
because it's almost meditative to me.
- I like the feeling of buying furniture.
That's, that's a good feeling.
You're like I knew I was.
I like eating on my furniture
(Joey chuckles)
when it's done though.
- Like I knew I was odd
where you go through the IKEA catalog
and you just like,
oh, that's a good
looking desk right there.
(Joey laughs)
- Catalog, now you're gonna
go there in person Garnt.
But to go to the IKEA mega store.
- You gotta sit down.
- You gotta feel the chat.
I don't really like.
- You gotta consider the furniture way.
All that shit.
- Everything needs to be considered.
- Consider the color
of it, the feel of it.
When did buying furniture become fun.
- Dude fuck! Welcome to adulthood baby.
- You know what was the
most annoying part of,
I bought that IKEA grass shit right?
- Yeah.
- Shit like generic grass
that goes on your floor.
- Patio.
- Whatever the fuck you want.
'Cause I wanted to have some grass
I could like, it feels nice.
It feels good, It feels good.
So, I bought it.
Turns out though, those IKEA grasses,
like the one thing that sucks
about them is that like,
you can't measure them.
(soft somber music)
You can't like fit them in precisely.
Like they either fit or they don't.
Like you can nearly have some of your
belt patio covered or you won't right.
'Cause they're like squares.
I think they're like five by five.
- Oh you got the squared tiles.
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause I got the ones.
I just got the roll 'cause
my balcony is massive.
- Well 'cause IKEA does like
square tiles of fake grass.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And so I didn't really
consider how it would fit,
but I've roughly measured it.
I thought I was too far,
fuckin like it, fuck it.
I realized that I can't block the drain,
the water drain.
Otherwise, no water again.
- [Garnt] Obviously.
- So, then I was like okay.
Well, now I either have
like a big chunk of my patio not covered,
and it looks weird.
Or I have my drain cover drawn,
I can't do, so I was like...
- Why not cover it with like there's...
'Cause I know the tiles,
there's like a wood tile
which has holes in it.
Can you just put that there?
- I have some wood tile on the other side.
- What about if you get the square
and you cut a hole
that partly fix the drain.
- So here we go.
- And then you can just plop it on top.
'Cause that's what I did at my place.
- Oh okay, so what I
did, it's not, it's not,
it's not like one big drain.
The drains in the corner somewhere else.
But it's like the thing
that leads into the drain.
- Oh yeah, yeah yeah.
- Something to be going in it.
So I was like, okay fuck it up.
Cut the shit in half.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It's like rock solid plastic.
- [Garnt] No I know.
- It is impossible to cut the shit.
- I was like what tools
did you use to cut it?
- My willpower. I literally
like, got this piece of plastic.
- A ball saw.
- It's like this big right?
Not even a saw, I literally just like
bent it together with my hands
like this right.
(Joey chuckles)
And then I just kept bending it like that,
and it weakened, and then
I did it the other way.
But the other way it's all plastics
so it hurts your hands to bend
it but wasn't fuckin bending.
So bend it the other way.
And I just kept doing this.
And it got loose enough
where I got some pliers,
and I was like cutting the plastic along.
- Jesus Christ!
- And its so goddamn long.
And then I had the problem of okay,
because of how these tiles work,
there's only like,
there's two sides,
like the one 90 corner, 90°C.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
This side and this side
are like the holes that you connect it to.
And these sides have like
the clips that it clips into.
So I had this problem now,
where some of the clips in
well, some of it doesn't.
So I'm like, don't step on that one,
when people go to the balcony.
'Cause I'm like,
yeah it's just all gonna like
fuckin break and fall
apart when you step on it.
But it looks nice.
We got it perfect.
- Yeah it looks nice.
- I hurt my hands and
it took so goddamn long.
- That's why I like the roll variety
because it's designed to be cut.
- But like I didn't have
a big enough area to warrant a whole roll.
- 'Cause it was a small area.
I just wanted grass. I
wanted to see more green.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
'Cause in my previous place,
I just had like the wood things.
The wood tiles.
- Those are nice.
- Which look nice,
but also, I think I just
prefer the feel of fake,
even if it's fake grass.
- Fake grass is nice to feel
That's why I got some parts wood,
just for, to have that
over the house. (mumbles)
But I have a grasp of where my feet go.
(Joey laughs).
- There's something
about with touching grass
with your feet feels good.
- What can I say,
we touch grass.
- Yeah, we touch grass.
- I touch grass every morning.
Next time you consider insulting me.
Remember I have grass, and that I touch.
- [Garnt] Even if it's fake grass.
- Whenever I see you
calling this is touch grass.
I'm like don't mind if I do.
I go out to my balcony.
- Ah! So much grass..
- Do you have a garden in Australia
when you were growing up?
Did you ever do the gardens?
- Yeah, my dad had a massive garden.
- Oh yeah, now that my dad's retired,
It's like all he does. Gardening.
- Would you ever consider a garden?
- I know I want a garden.
I don't wanna look after said garden.
- That's the point right?
The idea of a garden's nice because,
we have a garden in our English home.
As you know, you've been there.
And there was a point in time
where my parents would
just go to Thailand.
And there was a point in time
where I would work from
home, at that house.
And then, in the months that were away,
I noticed that the garden
just progressively looked like shit.
(Joey laughs)
And the grass would grow.
And then it was at that
point where I realized,
oh, someone's gonna
take care of this garden
for it to look good.
I don't wanna do that.
That's so much effort.
It's a big garden.
- Garnt these garden
plants are alive.
(Group laughs)
- That's true Garnt.
That's true
- Plants are living things.
- And ever since then,
I'm just like,
the idea of a garden is nice but just...
I've seen a lot of people
like Sidney's house is
like a massive garden.
And you can lose like
half a day or something.
Just like taking care of it.
- My dad regularly spends
multiple days taking care of it.
- Multiple days? And I'm just like...
- He loves it there.
It's like his new child.
But it looks amazing to be fair.
He does a really good job.
But to me it's just like
I don't know how to do is.
- I think I would
absolutely love it if I had
the time to take care of it.
- We haven't got to that age yet.
We can appreciate, just
being able to like,
pull out the lawn mower.
Have your coffee, or your
beer, and just go at it.
- Yes. Just grab a hose
and just hose down.
- Is that a good thing? I don't know.
- Like when you get older,
you probably enjoy those pleasures more.
I don't care to enjoy it.
- Because I remember when I was a kid,
my mom would be like,
Garnt, go cut the grass now.
It's your turn.
And I'm just like for fucks sake!
- They never made me do that.
I did a lot of the other chores.
- Oh they made me do that,
I just fuckin hated it.
- Because to me it was, my dad was like,
I'm not letting him do it, it's my garden.
It's mine, he's gonna fuck it up.
(Joey laughs)
- My dad was like,
if you don't do it,
then no dinner tonight.
And I was like, "Okay yes father."
And I do it, and I hated it.
- I had to do everything else.
- That's why I like the fake grass.
I'm like, "You're not grow."
- I hated putting up the laundry.
That's what I hated.
- I still hate putting out the laundry.
Which is what Sydney does actually.
Sydney loves that shit.
- But the way it was in my house is that
we had lodged a line and a big stick
that props up the line in the middle.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- So, it was always fuckin annoying
when it was windy doing this
when I was like smaller as well.
And this pole is massive.
So, I hated doing it.
Mom, these were pressed
memories by the way.
(Joey chuckles)
I don't like
doing the laundry now,
that's because of you, Joey?
(Group laughs)
- Childhood trauma.
- I fuckin hate that pole, piece of shit.
They still use this pole as well.
Get a new pole.
Get a better pole.
- Upgrade your pole.
- Get a new pole.
- Like I remember,
I remember when I moved
to my new place and,
'cause one of the big thing
about my new place that we've added,
is a dishwasher.
Which as you guys now,
you guys have dishwashers now right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- I sure do.
- Yeah, completely changed my life.
At the beginning, my mum was like,
my mum my entire life, right.
Has been like,
we don't need dishwasher.
My family doesn't need dishwasher.
That's just, that's just wasteful water.
That's just like your water
bill, and your electricity bill
is gonna go up, go up.
- The moment I found out
the dishwashers use
significantly less water.
I was like, well that's my excuse
for the rest of the timeline.
(Joey laughs)
- I'm like, I'm never, ever, ever,
washing the hands-like dish again.
I'm like you guys you're
killing the environment.
I can't possibly watch whatever it is.
- And ever since like I've
moved into my new place,
and like I've shown my mum the dishwasher.
And just like how much
less effort it takes to,
wash dishes after you cook.
- Will you have like a zoom
call with her and be like,
"Mom look, I press the go button."
- She's like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"I could be looking for a
dishwasher for Christmas."
(Group laughs)
- Just...
- Got em.
(Joey mimicking Anime tone)
- Conversion complete.
(Group laughs)
- I was like where was
this my entire life mom?
Was I just your dishwasher
your entire life,
and now that I'm gone,
you need an actual dishwasher?
Is that it?
- Pretty much yeah.
- That's pretty yeah.
- [Garnt] I see how it is mom.
I see how it is.
- Children are just cheap
appliance-like conversions right.
It's just like, I could spend
a lot of money on a lawnmower.
Or I could get my son to do
it, with the shitty lawnmower.
- Honestly, when I have children,
you bet your ass
(Joey laughs)
they get much old
to do the chores.
- You're really describing
why people had kids like
hundreds of years ago.
(Garnt laughs)
That's why they had so many.
'Cause they'll like well, I can't do it.
- So you that get married
into a household was like,
all right how many things
do we need to do every day? Seven.
All right, prepare to have seven kids.
- I'm not paying for an
assistant. I'm getting a kid.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- My PA is gonna be my kid.
- Sell my stock son.
What will you be selling?
- Hiring and clean out.
That's like privileged rich people shit.
Getting a kid,
(Joey laughs)
now that's the real shit.
- That's a lie fuck right there.
- One thing, sorry to go on a tangent.
I just realized fuck kids for real.
- Please don't, please don't.
(Group laughs)
- Not that kind. Don't play Samsung music.
One thing that I hope I
get less of next year.
The only regret is that
I haven't told these fuckin NFT companies
that email me every day to fuck off!
(Joey laughs)
Fuck off! Stop emailing
me about making NFT.
Fuck off!
- We all get them and I just...
- So it's not just emails,
it's tweets as well.
- Did you know notice
on some of the tweets
where it's just like a bot
that gets like retweeted,
to be like, you can buy like,
I don't know how me tweeting about
like Anime TDS or something
has anything to do with fuckin NFTs.
- It's either this bot saying,
"Hey, you can do something with this NFT."
Or it's this one guy who every
tweet is consistently like,
"Hey, you should read this one model."
- I never got a visibly
angry email before,
but this one made me like, I shouted.
It was this one, where it says,
"Business invitation from the
most anticipated NFT game."
I've never wanted to hear
that string of woods ever.
And the fact that I got that email
made me actually...
- What the fuck
is an NFT game?
(crew murmurs)
- I don't know! I don't
want it! Stop emailing me!
I hate this bro.
If you're into it, that's fine.
I don't mind, but why do they
shove it down our throat?
Fuck off!
- Because it's NextGen dude, it's NextGen.
Everyone needs to be up to
date on that NextGen shit.
- 'Cause what it feels like is that
this thing is this thing that I have
like very little knowledge about it.
It's just getting shoved
down my throat right.
- I understand it and I don't like it.
- I don't even understand
and I still hate it.
- Because of the shit that they like,
the fuckin stuff they say on Twitter.
It's like mind numbing.
I hate it's like...
Twitter since NFTs has
become somewhat worse.
I don't understand how Twitter got worse.
But like NFTs made Twitter
so much more wrong.
And then every goddamn YouTuber
is like somehow using NFTs
for like scams as well,
it's awful.
- Are they?
- So many YouTubers using NFT
for like scamming stuff.
- Can you explain to me
and perhaps the audience
that doesn't know.
Explain it like I'm five.
What the fuck even is an NFT?
- So, there's like a...
You're basically buying the proof
that you own a piece of artwork right.
- But it's digital right?
- But it's a digital piece of artwork.
It's not a physical piece,
but in the blockchain which is kind of...
I'm not getting into that.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah don't go into that.
- Explain it like I'm five.
Explain it like I'm five.
- In like proof to the
world that you're...
Essentially you are paying
for the proof that you
own something right.
That's the most basic
way I can explain it.
- So you get a token
that can't be replicated
to say you own this thing.
- So it's like a certificate
of authenticity kinda.
- That's exactly what it means.
- Right, right, right.
- That's why people are buying
artwork, digital artwork,
for like ridiculous
amounts of money because,
in a sense, even though you can (chuckles)
right click and save as that one.
(Group laughs)
- Got em.
- Like there's a token,
or like a certificate that says
you own the "Original"
piece of the artwork.
- It's so fuckin.
- Even though it's like digital.
- That's dumb as fuck.
- I have friends, good friends,
who like have made a lot of money from it,
and that's what they do.
And they produce them themselves and they,
it's all for them. I
don't mind them doing it.
I'm not like you can't do it.
It's like just this whole aspect
of shoving it down everyone's throat.
- It's just a craze.
- Because people are
trynna make money from it.
So the only way to get
money and make money
from a a lot of them, not
all of them are scams.
There are a lot of scams as well.
There are so many scams.
And there's like so
many scandals and stuff
'Cause there's no regulation or anything.
- So do people like by certain NFTs
and then resell them at a higher
price or something.
- Yeah, a lot of it yeah.
- So it's just like an investment.
(group laughs)
- That's how they frame it.
- That's how they phrase it yeah.
- But the stuff like,
there's been stuff like insider trading
where like websites that
sell NFTs and showcase them.
They have like things.
There was like one case where
this thing where they basically
promote an NFT every week,
and they guy, one of the
like COOs or something
new which NFT was coming up.
So he would buy a bunch of that,
that type of artwork.
And then when it went up,
he would sell it and make a ton of money.
But there's no laws against it
'cause it's not considered insider trading
because it's cryptocurrency.
- The siren police isn't gonna come.
- So there's like this, it's
just the wild west right now.
And for some people it's
great. They love that.
- It's a place where,
because there's no rules,
there's no regulation.
A lot of people can get scammed.
A lot of people can make...
- A lot of scams.
- A lot of money very, very fast.
And it's just kind of like a
toxic environment right now.
- It's really bad.
- Yeah and it sounds like it.
- I get so many scams.
And I hate the fact that
YouTubers have started
promoting them and doing it.
- Of course they have.
- It' fuckin awful.
"Oh you have really is
my NFT yeah yeah..."
- Which is like a shame 'cause I like,
I feel like the idea and the technology
has like so much potential,
and now it's just being used for like
really shitty things basically.
- And there's also the criticism
that it's terrible for the environment
and stuff like that and whatnot.
- Wait how's it terrible
for the environment?
- Oh 'cause the (mumbles). Oh God!
- Do I have to go do my own research?
- The way that like...
how the system works,
it uses a shit ton of computing power
to have the blockchain.
It's quite inefficient in general,
it wastes a lot of energy to
run these fuckin nonsense.
- Basically like, some
of these cryptocurrencies
at the moment, have as much energy usage
as some countries to run right?
- Genuinely (chuckles) It's insane.
- Like the network that NFTs run on,
which is called Ethereum.
I think uses as much energy as like Sweden
or one of those countries.
- I'm not like this boomer
who's like anti-progress
and anti technology.
I'm all for like good technology.
But it just feels like
the way it's been going
is such a fuckin mess and
it's like, it's just awful.
- Well, because it's actually
been shoved down my throat.
I did actually do like
my research and reading
into this thing because like,
if there's this thing,
like I like to understand things.
And I feel like,
the problem now is that,
it's just so fuckin you,
that nobody knows what
the fuck to do with them.
It's the wild west.
And I feel like as like,
as the years progress and
it becomes more stable
then this could, there is
potential for this technology
to be used for something actually good.
And it will, I feel like it,
this technology will be more sustainable
in the future as well as
cryptocurrency is kinda figure out,
"Hey, let's build a system that doesn't,
"like burn the entire Amazon rainforest
"to get running right."
But I feel just right now,
it is like, I'm staying
the fuck away from this.
- Oh yeah I'm not touching
it like they need...
Although that's the last thing they want.
It does need some kind of
regulation in some sense,
to stop all these fuckin scams.
And the reason why I know
how many scams there are,
is because they always reach out to us,
to ask us to promote them.
There's so many that
ask us to promote them.
And this is like this
fuckin nonsense and be like,
"Hey, we're like a Badger
Poop NFT, wanna... "
And it's like fuck off!
(Garnt laughs)
Just fuck off.
Like it's so crazy.
- Are you looking forward to
NFTs being added to
your favorite video games?
(Joey laughs)
- Oh my God!
I think if it gets to a
point where it's like,
it's not like fuckin burning
the planet and it's chill.
And it's not so scummy.
- 'Cause like real, like I see this shit.
I'm just like the CSGO skin community
is like salivating right now. Oh my God!
- Oh my God!
(Garnt laughs)
Yeah NFT skins and memes
surprise came over.
It'll probably get there at some point.
I can see it happening.
I can easily see it happening,
if you having one of a kind skin.
- I'm just like so out of the loop
with like that kind of
like NFT, crypto and shit...
- Honestly good.
- I feel like this is what
my grandma must have felt
when VR was introduced.
It's like where it's just like,
I just can't wrap my head around.
Like I did ask,
like when you said Ethereum,
I was like oh okay yeah.
I've heard of that.
Because the first time I heard Ethereum.
I was like, I'm pretty
sure you can collect that
in StarCraft right.
(Garnt laughs)
Like that's what it sounded like to me.
And then I was like, oh wait no,
it's like a crypto thing, okay
nevermind I don't wanna...
I feel very old right now my bad.
- That's the only trend I
hope changes or dies down.
That's all I want. I don't
care about anything else.
I'm just stop it now.
- I just want some
actual cool applications
that are not just selling
overly priced artwork,
which is just the exact
same fuckin artwork.
The amount of times
I've seen that monkey NFT.
- Oh my fuckin God!
- Like with just different skins.
I don't even know what that monkey NFT is.
- "I've got the skin moist
wearing the pirate hat,"
and it's like fuck off!
Do you realize how stupid this sounds.
- [Garnt] Oh God!
- At least if some guy spends
talking $200 on a Monet,
he's got a fuckin Monet,
I don't think that's good either,
but at least he's got the fuckin painting.
- Yeah exactly.
- Didn't burn down the
rainforest to get a fuckin token.
I understand it's such a boom right now.
I hate all this stuff man
it sucks. The scam suck too.
And yeah again, I hope
that it gets some kind of,
I hope that
it claims up its act.
- Regulation.
- And it stops being so shit.
- Yeah because like I was reading up about
like the possible
applications NFTs could have.
And like, you have a Non Fungible...
NFT stands for No Fungible Tokens.
So of course, right now it's been used
as a certificate to say,
you own this stuff,
but it has like a lot more
applications above that.
You can think about hey,
sending over certification
to say hey, this person,
let's say has a driver's license,
or is certified,
has a master's degree or something
along those lines.
- Along those lines yeah.
- Where it's like one centralized unit
that anyone can check.
So we don't rely on like some companies,
like forging driver's
license or documentation.
- Or like have to got
all the way to like...
- Or even thinking about house ownership
or any kind of ownership.
- The amount of fuckin paperwork.
Think of how much it
can revolutionize Japan.
If there was one system that said,
this person owns this,
and this person owns that.
That's like, that's got
so much potential to like,
like reduce the paperwork by tenfold.
You gotta give Japan time.
They've just discovered
databases so like...
(Group laughs)
- Japan still uses the fuckin desk card.
- They've just discover what Excel is.
Maybe like 30, 40 years time for them.
- I think there's a lot of exciting things
that it could be useful,
but right now it is...
- That sounds cool right.
- Like yeah, that sounds
like a real life use.
I remember like, the only
piece of news I saw about NFT
is when it was first popping up
was like the original Nyan cat GIF
got like sold as an NFT for like
some stupid amount of money.
And I was like, who?
- What I wanna know is, who sold it?
And how did they prove that
they had ownership of it?
- I think it might've
been the original creator.
- [Crew Member] I think, even
like the original creator
was like, there's actually
a loophole for this.
We can't actually like...
This concept is actually
not applicable to what...
- Yeah that's, that's the biggest loophole
I don't understand.
- So what we're saying is,
we can't authenticate whether
it's authentic or not.
(Group and crew laughing)
- [Crew Member] Yeah,
that's what they've said.
- What the fuck!
(Group laughs)
Does that not seem ass backwards to you.
- [Crew Member] Yeah, and
then someone took their image
and like "Ah, yeah, whatever."
- My God! (chuckles)
- Yeah, there's still
a lot about this place
I don't understand.
So I'm not gonna,
I'm only gonna comment
on things that I do know.
- Yeah I just want less scums.
Just to put it less scums.
- [Crew Member] So like for example like
a single Ethereum transaction
consumes as much electricity
as an average US household
uses in a work week,
and has a covered footprint
equivalent to 140,893 Visa,
like for example Visa
credit card transactions,
or 10,595 hours of watching YouTube.
- What the fuck!
(soft upbeat music)
- So that's like every NFT transaction
that's being made right now.
- That's fuckin insane.
- [Crew Member] So 10,000
hours of watching YouTube
is more than that fuckin (mumbles)
- What the fuck! Why?
- Yeah right now it is...
- We truly live in a society.
(Group and crew laughing)
- Bro, that's actually depressing.
That's so depressing to hear. Fuck!
- What a way to end the year. (laughs)
- Well, happy new year gamers!
Hope you get a good one.
- Happy new year.
- Hopefully next year you won't be
as depressed hearing that.
- Merry Christmas if you celebrate it,
if not happy holidays,
if not, have a good day.
- I'm gonna buy
an NFT of my favorite...
- Fuck off.
Fortnite narrative skin.
That's what I'm gonna buy.
- Oh my God,
I'm fuckin getting out.
Get me outta here. Get me outta here!
- Did they sell the GIF of Genjutsu?
(Group laughs)
- I want my resin gun,
thank you very much.
(Group and Crew laughing)
- [Crew Member] He maybe out of chakra
but he ain't out of bullets.
- He ain't out of bullets.
- Well hope you enjoyed
this episode of Trash Taste.
- [Group] Yes.
- Hey look at all these
Patreons though.
- The last one for 2021.
- We hope you've had.
I hope all of these guys are having
a very Merry Christmas right now.
- Yes if not happy holidays
and thanks for another
entire year of Trash Taste.
Next time you see us will
be the first day of 2022.
Yes it's fuckin terrifying
to say out 2022.
(mumbles)
- 2022 However.
(beep)
(Crew and group laughs)
- It's two minutes to go.
Oh, there it is right now.
- There it is!
- 2022 is come
around the corner.
- Come on now.
(Group laughs)
- Do you wanna do the final answer drill.
- Yes but, if you'd
like to support the show
for next year 2022.
Because we have a lot more going on,
then make sure to join us
on patrion.com/trashtaste
Also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the subreddit.
And if you hate our faces,
listen to us on Spotify.
But yeah thanks for 2021.
- Thanks for an amazing 2021.
You guys I mean,
it's been a fuckin fantastic
year for Trash Taste.
- [Connor] Absolutely.
- We've talked more
about individual channel,
but Trash Tastes just like,
it keeps coming man and...
- We don't have to talk about Trash Taste.
You guys know how good Trash Taste is on.
- You guys no how it is.
- Your here every week.
- So, we will see you guys in 2022.
- [Group] Bye.
- It's the most I've ever
yawned in one episode.
(Joey laughs)
(soft upbeat music)